four three two
hey guys well i'm back ila is
coming she's at the doctor
and she's coming she'll be here any
minute she's just running a little late
and i know there's just way too much on
the line when i'm late these days
but to be honest you guys want to tank
my feet for being late
you know if you guys want to take my
feet score my wikifeed score for trying
to produce the best show possible
then just oh ela's here oh my god the
timing was so good we just started
i literally just went live everybody
you were flying looking fantastic
i love that shirt it looks like a
watercolor on there
on the shirt it is directly on its
airspace
hairbrush directly on the shirt by uh
this girl loyal pop on instagram loyal
pup
yeah she loyal she's she's very loyal
let me make sure i said it right
actually catching me on the spot here
yes loyal pop girl you about to make me
act up
that's hot girl you're about to make me
do something about it
you want to oh my god oh well hey now
anyway today's episode is sponsored by
stamps.com oh we got coffee and
everything wow what a service
stamps.com blue chew and upstart um
yeah you know people always threatening
to tank my wikifeed score
i'm being sued by jake paul um i've
lost the title you know somebody passed
me on wikifeet yesterday
there's really nothing left for me to
lose so if you guys don't want to just
like support me and the highs
and the lows then there's nothing i can
do you know what i mean like
how dare you hold that over my head it's
all i have left in this world
right and you guys have made a mockery
of it and dan you always try to pretend
like it's not your fault but i will
never forgive you
for going on discord and saying wouldn't
it be funny
for everybody to go up vote abe's feet
okay
not a joke does that have to do with
downvoting your feed
because you because you're encouraging
mutiny don't you understand that yeah
thank you yeah i guess so
daddy daddy me i want to talk about feet
anyway um you know there was actually
some really big drama
regarding wiki feet is that
someone passed me do you guys have a
screenshot of someone passing me because
he kind of got
oh yeah yeah it's on the net so someone
momentarily passed me and this is kind
of like the price we play
for the games we play right it's because
i used to be a seven
and this guy managed to pass me
momentarily
with a 6.17 now i'm back on top
but i'm just saying like i i don't know
if you guys
do you guys want to watch anybody who's
not number one on wikipedia you know
it's like
all of a sudden i'm number two it's just
not that your top pictures now i say
trisha
right it's because i showed my feet on
the beetlejuice
episode daddy um so
you know i don't know it's like guys i'm
doing my best out here i'm dealing with
a lot of stuff
and you know for you guys to hold that
over my head just i don't know
you know right it's like kendrick lamar
said when the [ __ ] hit the fan are you
still a fan
when the [ __ ] hit the foot are you still
a soldier when the foot
smushed when the foot waffle stone hits
the fan and it looks awful would you
still have about the foot
do you know what a wonderful stomp is
yes you told me many times ethan
it's when you're
well some the viewers may not know what
a waffle swamp is
it's it when you poop in the shower and
you stomp it down with your foot
and so the question is are you still a
fan of the foot
after the waffle snake i find myself
laughing like wendy williams
not intentional i don't know if it's
subconscious
but it's worrying me i've been doing
they're like
it's so fun
now we've got a really great show for
you guys today um
white cloth gabe is calling in the
fabled it's friday baby
[ __ ] [ __ ] and we're all going to have
our lives it's friday inaugural white
claws
i've never had a white man me neither so
i'm going to crack it open with white
claw in honor of this beautiful friday
afternoon
so is there alcohol in it yes five
percent just like a beer
it's like a tasty beer people love this
[ __ ] [ __ ] fact you know only
the weekend baby [ __ ] game
such a legend it's only got 100 calories
which is kind of crazy because that's
what a beer has right i mean more or
less
yeah it's about the same there's a
little bit of sugar in it and a little
bit of carbonation
ian you're a fan of the white claw right
really wait what
what flavor you got there i've got
raspberry do you approve
oh aren't you the one that bought these
no i bought it oh
i have a variety you're going to open
raspberry with
white cloth what should i be drinking
listen you gotta get that mango [ __ ] man
well i got a variety pack but there's no
makeup there's no mango in the variety
pack does everybody have a white claw
i got a 12-pack exactly to get toasted
in his new apartment
they looked at me at the liquor store
this morning it was like at nine like
they're like no one yeah
same i felt i felt weird buying don't
worry you guys everybody's buying
alcohol at nine in the morning
trust me it's alcohol store they're open
for a reason
they're like why was that a grocery
store so it was a little weird
you're getting prepared for the weekend
baby [ __ ]
love you got a white claw you guys drink
that out there
no no white flo in sweden sadly sweden's
behind bro they're better than us yeah
they got something better probably so we
have white claw gabe calling in
we have donald trump everybody in the
chat saying
lime that's what oh lime's the
government i do have
there's lime and there's variety that's
good oh well give me a like yeah
i don't want to i don't have
i mean we can ask him what's his
favorite flavor you know
i'm guessing it's not raspberry though
raspberry and black cherry are the black
cherry
baby baby natural lime let's go
by the way not sponsored by white claw
wish it was
so and then you guys all uh donald trump
is calling in again too
you guys remember j uh oh i don't think
we've talked about it
um maybe we should explain
well don't so you guys may have seen
this jake donald trump
called jake paul for some ungodly reason
and this is the photo that jake took
he is trump's face face timing he's
trump uses my angles oh my god
use this angle apparently you're
supposed to do this angle for like
to look good right this is my angle when
i want to look bad
um that's trump so we're gonna so the
president
of the former president oh yeah i know
listen
so good jake you're very talented young
man you're doing amazing things in the
boxing uh can i get you down to uh
i'd love to get you down to mar-a-lago
we're doing fundraising and we want to
include the young
people i know your dad is a
white trash and i would be interested
i don't know but anyway the president is
going to call in and talk about what
they discussed together so that should
be interesting right
yeah daddy are you kidding me
so um and a lot of other really fun
segments we've been working hard
although the topic i'm sure everybody
wants to hear me talk about
first is that
it's true the headlines are true
i am being sue or what we are well you
didn't do anything but you uh while our
company is being sued how should i put
it
all right here's the here's the deal
triller
is suing us for copyright infringement
thank you they're booing not booing me
right no yeah
yeah good thank you just making sure
um and i don't
it's funny because i found out when this
press release went out
and i was like i'm sorry who's suing me
i know it's so weird to find out that
you're being sued through an article
yeah it's like is it actually happening
i was like what maybe it's a typo
i don't know yeah it's not a typo
unfortunately
so you know the lawsuit itself is like a
big
lawsuit against you know all these
there's all these streaming
uh piracy websites that stream the link
yeah and so they're suing all these
people and there's been people who
re-uploaded the fight to youtube for a
bunch of people to watch
and they're suing them and so they've
lumped me in here
what i can only determine is out of
spite
because i clearly first of all my
coverage of the fight
is was totally fair use i showed 45
seconds
of jake knocking out ben
and commented over the whole thing
nonstop
and you know his part listen i've i'm
the
they should know and you guys all know
there's been one fair use lawsuit that's
been
won and it was by us
it's funny because i was talking to my
lawyers about this and they're like you
know it's
you know what's crazy is that our first
lawsuit
is going to be used as case precedent
and our second lawsuit
they're going to cite our first lawsuit
and the litigation pretty funny oh man
so our first is
it's ironic but our first lawsuit is
actually going to help us
that's why it's so good that you guys
actually fought that because we went
through so much on that first one
it was a lot of everything
like stress and a lot of hours that we
put into it too oh yeah
we had to actually like we reviewed
every motion
and like i didn't trust the lawyers
because i was like this is my whole
[ __ ] life
put a lot of work into it ourselves i
turned into a kind of a [ __ ]
let's say a pseudo lawyer myself both of
us i found myself reading on this
motions in english
like lawyer language and and um so
it's kind of nice to know in a way that
it's being used oh yeah maybe for us but
probably for other people too i don't
know
oh of course dude the that first lawsuit
is
well if you go to the copyright if you
go to publish law and copyright
we are among like a very small group of
actual established law lawsuits that are
used as president
you can go to the cop like a copyright
section of of
the government websites and see our
lawsuit there it's being studied in
schools i've heard that a bunch of times
being like the case is being studied so
shout out to matt hoss for that shout
out to his family yeah
so that's so on the fair use aspect
um on the various have it's easy
yeah and then they're well i mean it's a
[ __ ] claim really
it's totally fair use yeah it's just
that's why i think it's like a spite
yeah because uh you know
we've been talking about the allegations
against jake paul covered by the new
york times
and it listen
i think i don't think it's a kuwaiti
sentence that of all the people in the
world that have talked about
uh this fight that we are somehow
singled out because in the lawsuit and
the press were like they're like
this guy h3 it's like okay really like
there's plenty of people who've been
showing this fight especially when they
talk about rebroadcasting that's not
something we
right it did so that's the other leg of
this lawsuit is that there's like the
fair use
i'm not quite sure what exactly they're
suing us for either because
it's a huge list of people they're suing
most of them are like weird websites
based in like god knows where they're
probably never even get a dime from it's
like
i don't know how you even locate these
people yeah and then
um and then there's a few other you know
uh there's a few other people
what are you uh should i be reading what
you guys are okay
so um you know
then they added like an amended
complaint which is like part two
of a lawsuit it's like when you add more
so they amended the original complaint
and that's when they added us
oh really yeah that's why it was
confusing because i looked at the
original website or the lawsuit and i
was like i'm not on this what are they
talking about
and then at the bottom of the amended
complaint was when they added more
defendants
were at the bottom so it's like i don't
know if they're sui i really don't know
to be frank so that's why i think the
the lawsuit is
uh quite quite frivolous and dumb
and it seems to be motivated out of
spite if i had to take a guess
but who knows you know we're trying to
figure out to be
you know i'm in a much different
situation that i wasn't in during the
last lawsuit so i'm not
you know listen i don't want to ever be
in a lawsuit
and yeah i'm i'm i'm i'm
walking delicately because i want to i
just want to resolve this in mediation
with them i don't want to go to
litigation with them
so i'm gonna we're just gonna try to be
nice
i'm gonna try to be nice for now
so that we can maybe just resolve this
in mediation so it doesn't have to get
litigated
but so i'm gonna just bite my tongue for
now
about triller and jake paul you know
they've got an interesting case i'll
just say that they've got an interesting
case
and um a lot of instant a lot of that
out you know
uh really compelling stuff
and we're just going to try to be nice
for now
wait i'm confused because i i had heard
from a really reliable source that you
were going to jail for five years
oh yeah keemstar is tap dancing all over
twitter that i'm going to jail
i thought for sure you were going to the
big house oh and then he goes
oh god can you guys actually pull up
some of that because i feel like the
keemstar aspect is the funniest part of
this
he's been tap dancing that i'm going to
jail first of all it's a civil lawsuit
dumb [ __ ]
i'm not going to jail for a civil
lawsuit
does he does he not understand no
difference between
criminals but also keemstar wants to
live in
he's so desperate for me to like go to
jail and take like an l he's like taking
no five years in jail
he's so desperate for me to go to jail
and ruin my life that he wants to live
in a world
where you can go to jail
for watching a video something that he
does
every day like do you understand how
[ __ ]
how uh self-defeating that is [ __ ]
good luck ethan it's just crazy how
[ __ ] stupid he is
clown star
oh yeah then he didn't he say on his
podcast he goes he goes okay
the max damages per stream
is 150 000 for pirated that's the max
damage
uh but and then so he goes okay and his
podcast has a million views
so he goes here's how much ethan's going
to owe
150 billion i ethan is going to owe
the trailer 150 billion dollars i was
like holy [ __ ]
even bill gates ex-wife isn't gonna be
able to afford that that would ruin her
even
that would ruin them yeah so i'm 150
billion dollars i'm gonna owe
fantastic yeah really cross the line
yeah i'm sorry of all the things i've
done uh showing a clip and reacting to
it was by far my gravest crime
look it's good it's got a clown brain
it operates on like clown logic right
you just have to
keep that in mind yeah and keep starting
like
yeah exactly he's such a [ __ ]
dumbass the essay victims are you know
they could just say no call me later
yeah when the police
walk off don't worry keemstar when the
police show up i'll be i'll just say no
yeah so yeah
clown logic yeah so keemstar has been
tap dancing that i'm going to prison
it's [ __ ] amazing anyway
i listen obviously lawsuits are super
stressful so yes it's
really annoying that i'm being sued and
really stressful
you know the good situation the last
time we got sued we were
much more uh
i had a lot less money okay
and so not only that but i felt like the
importance of the case was was a big
deal and
i you know so it was that first time the
first time we got sued it like was
life ruining for like two years to be
totally frank
a lot of the issue with the last lawsuit
too was like finding a good lawyer
not knowing anything about lawsuits and
the legal ramifications of stuff
happening to learn everything finding
out that our original lawyers were like
total frauds
having to fire them doing all this [ __ ]
finding new learner i mean it was such
such a horrible
situation this time i've got great
lawyers
i've got a i got a little bit more coin
so
you know there's certain stress factors
that are less for me now
but obviously i mean look legal lawsuits
are [ __ ] terrible you know
if they want to take this thing all the
way it's going to be a year of grueling
litigation it's going to cost me
hundreds of thousands of dollars
and um it's going to be [ __ ] awful
but i'm gonna bite i'm gonna bite my
tongue
you know because there's plenty more i
could say
about jake paul and triller that i
just want to be nice for now
you know just being nice
so that's it i mean do you guys have any
questions uh
well maybe should we explain the
wednesday
oh so the wednesday app i filmed yeah so
we filmed an episode on wednesday
which was like my kind of snap reaction
to the lawsuit let's say there was a
snap
for sure i hadn't discussed with my
lawyers yet
and so i was like oh these [ __ ]
are suing me well
here's all my unfiltered thoughts
and you know guys i wasn't there and it
was ethan it was off the rails
off the rails and it was off the rails
officially
and you know um
you know uh
listen i was like okay i talked to my
laura he's like maybe it's best if we
just uh
sideline that until we can do some
mediation
i was like okay fair enough so
yeah we shot the episode but we're like
okay let's just hold off for
for a minute you know
but the good news is you know we went to
disneyland with trisha for her birthday
yeah and we shot a frenemy's vlog
which was super fun and hopefully we'll
post it this weekend
oh well and maybe you said it sorry i
was just talking to
the roost um the episode that
we filmed on wednesday we had originally
said we were going to release on this
weekend but it's looking
like that probably it's not happening
yeah it probably can't happen
because um the lawyers are like i just
don't i
want to say everything but i want to
just hold my tongue and be a good boy
for now
so it'll be the last episode of the h3
podcast i know maybe we can release it
someday well everything's settled yeah
it depends on what happens but
like it depends on how mediation goes
but we can release it it's too bad
because
it was a funny one and it's approved by
youtube and i used some
strong language in that boy i was like
wow youtube gave it the green light i
was like wow they must hate jake ball
too
because i said some [ __ ] horrible
things in that [ __ ]
you know so we'll see what happens but
god i want to say everything you guys
you know i have a problem i like to
[ __ ] say everything that's on my mind
and um yeah and i just you know it's so
hard not to
it's so hard not to but we're going to
wait and see what happens and then
depending on how it goes you're going to
hear daddy's full thoughts
or not or maybe i'll be like you know
what maybe i'll be like what was that
what was that that was joe biden saying
i probably shouldn't say that
yeah yeah i'm with you i i shouldn't say
i'm gonna say something i don't i i
probably shouldn't say
yeah exactly i'm with joe there you know
when you hear that
as a listener you're like yeah don't say
it yeah when the listeners are telling
me don't say it then i know i'm really
bad at it
no no i probably best i don't
oh man people saying uh do it as a
members episode that doesn't really
it's still yeah it can't happen yeah
yeah
your honor that was only for the members
not that i'm saying i'm not saying
anything
look i'm not saying anything that's like
will hurt the lawsuit i'm saying things
that will hurt
our chances of a successful mediation
you know what i mean
right hard feelings it will hurt
feelings yes
um and we we feelings are very important
to us here so there'll be two outcomes
either i'll come out with that
lost episode or i'll come out next week
and be like jake paul
is my best friend we've buried the
hatchet and
triller by the way is a phenomenal uh
media organization that i have the
utmost respect for
so you'll still be two outcomes
and keemstar still a clown oh keemstar
is a [ __ ]
absolute ask keemstar is probably the
worst human being alive and i
and i say that with peace and love
[Laughter]
and shout out to his family i'm right
you think klein is going to jail and
he's going to be paying
150 billion dollars in damages
imagine actually believing that i saw
i've seen lots of people
apparently who don't like me just
celebrating that i'm going to jail
i was like wow yes well keemstar and
olive is like lackeys they're all like
you know
yeah copyright infringement people
should go to jail for that they're like
cool
they're like oh it's happening to ethan
yeah i believe copyright infringement
should go to jail
people who spend their whole [ __ ]
lives
using the fair use case that i [ __ ]
sweat and died for you know what i mean
right it's like a romeo juliet
so that's pretty much all i can say
about it now but depending on what
happens i'm gonna be having
a lot more to say about it peace and
love
but you know i just think that uh all
right for now
interesting you know it's a
well-conceived lawsuit with a lot of ins
and outs and i totally
see kind of like you know shredder is
looking at you like move on
you said you're going to move on moving
like come on
all right shredder
oh there's one thing oh there's one
keemstar thing though that i think you
all got to see
before i move on it's not even related
so keemstar
goes he's he's just so excited about me
going to jail
that he's making these huge mistakes
why ethan klein is facing up to five
years in prison explained
his video is really pointless by the way
he's just like
the obvious [ __ ] you know whatever not
insightful
but because he's in such a rush to tap
dance on my grave
he put out his desktop now if you want
to know what a serial killer uh
keemstar is you'll notice the folders
okay oh nice the best for last we've got
um h3h3 crimes
oh it says crimes yeah it's better than
seriously crimes
and in the video he opened it and it's
just the footage from the podcast
episode so it's crime
yeah it's a crime he's like dear fbi
[Laughter]
i've sent you a zip detailing uh extreme
cyber crimes
pyro it's like he's still got a chip on
his shoulder over pyro i mean
dude you are psychotic you got a drama
from like 20
yes trisha of course i think but here's
the most
i don't know where you're sick [ __ ]
[ __ ] etika oh god
a folder yeah about
etika on his desktop okay
a youtuber okay a youtuber that he
bullied
essentially into unaliving himself
two years ago
this man has been hasn't has been
resting in peace for two years
and he has a folder on his desktop that
is like
dexter yeah he is like a super
killer he's he has he has memorabilia
from this incident why would he have a
folder
dedicated to etika a man who's been
deceased for two years
you know every normal person has a
folder of their best friend
on their desktop right they're just
really good friends
right right that's what that's what keem
would always say i mean i
hate listen i'm just i honestly sent
shivers down my [ __ ] spine super
creepy when i saw
and people called him out and he deleted
this tweet yeah he like realized he
[ __ ] up
so keemstar is getting so excited about
the process of me going to jail for
copyright infringement you know the
greatest crime of all
[Laughter]
i mean this is some weird dexter serial
killer [ __ ] can you imagine this being
your desktop like does he have any
anything else going on
no he's got he has game ape escape so
light-hearted with all these other
he goes should i play should i go on
steam spotify or look through my
edica folder today or my teresa takedown
what do i feel like doing today gamecube
oh should i play gamecube uh
oh by the way gamecube folder is that
possibly could that possibly be like a
how do you call those uh virtual window
oh an emulator is this an
oh that's a good idea i understand how
illegal that is that is copyright
infringement
and look at the bottom in the middle 4k
video downloader that's to rip
[Applause]
i need to make a folder on my desktop
star crimes
and this video is in it this screenshot
is number one yo
4k video downloader first of all that's
the smoking gun he's been ripping videos
gamecube how many games do you think he
has in there that's 150 000
and five years for each title
age of empire you better have bought
that
i hope you paid that yeah
that's [ __ ] up can you imagine
you know i'm making jokes about the
theft because it's so stupid but the
etiquette thing is truly
uh so disturbing directions i don't even
know do you rank oh it's just such a
heavy thing
why and like you know this is like this
horrible thing that happened
in in the youtube community in space
that we all are like let's just
you know let let's just move on you know
and
try to like just let the guy rest in
peace and keemstar is one of those
people
yet he is constantly every day he starts
up his computer and looks at this
etiquette folder
and there's not a lot of stuff on his
desktop too he keeps it tidy right
this is a desktop that like is neatly
manicured
just the priorities
this music is fantastic exactly it's so
empty other than like his
his uh kill orders it's like one bullet
for trisha
one bullet for a straight street you
know like in uh unbiased news
and peaky blind doors yeah he writes the
name the name on the book dude
this guy is truly a sick in the head the
rest
is the blackboard
i'm just blown away you know i truly am
and yeah
you know
dude i'm just i'm speechless okay so
that's it you know this was the best
thing to come out of the lawsuit in my
opinion
it was keemstar that's definitely a lie
yeah sick [ __ ] he is and then quickly
erasing it
yeah that's like a big [ __ ] up in his
world
yeah and he just totally exposed himself
just because he was so happy about me
going to jail apparently
that's like dexter for getting a piece
of hair somewhere
yeah he's got like an event where he
keeps the blood drops you know yeah
oh but he made us he made a he made a
mistake at the crime scene
because he was so happy about their
mistake yeah yeah
come on keemstar you're better [ __ ]
bad guy yes we all know that
you know and it's such a [ __ ]
hypocrite loser too for having all this
pirated [ __ ] on his desktop while
talking about me going to jail
anyway yeah shout out keemstar uh we're
at 30.
now oh wow that was fast yep so are we
doing
oh just stamps just stamps
[Music]
so what are we doing with the other two
we're moving them to another week
well that's fine so we're not losing
them that's what he said yeah fantastic
we love that folks
all right well we got stamps.com
i love stamps you put them on letters
and stamps are like magic you put them
on a letter
and then they teleport to a new uh
location
i know you're saying it ironically but i
do love stamps i'm not
why what i don't know because he's
sounding like what
you you put it in the nose well i'm
being joking about them teleporting but
stamps are amazing
i love stamps.com okay why are you still
going to the post office
you're paying full price for postage no
stamps.com you don't have to go anymore
mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your
computer you're sending letters packages
and you're gonna pay less and a lot less
with discounted rates from usps ups and
more
sams.com save businesses thousands of
hours and tons of money every year
sams.com is a service of the us postal
service and ups right to your computer
it's a must-have for any business
whether you're a small office sending
invoices
a side hustle on etsy
stop shipping out a shop shipping out
orders or just navigating this
complex crazy world we live in samps.com
can handle it all with ease
no no wonder over 1 million businesses
chose stamps.com for their mailing and
shipping folks
dude all you gotta do is sit at your
computer
there you can print posters 24 7 for any
letter any package any class email
anywhere you want to send
once your mail is ready you schedule it
for a pickup or you drop it off it's
that simple
and with stamps.com you get discounts of
up to 40 percent
what come on
40 off post office rates and up to 66
percent
what six six you heard that right 66
off ups shipping rates come on
not to mention snaps.com is a fraction
of the cost of those expensive postage
meters
still don't know what that means but
i'll read it for them
i've been saying posted i should just
look it up it's a it's a weight right
you just weigh your mail
sure sure nobody knows what a postage
meter is
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money it's no wonder nearly 1
million small businesses already use
stamps.com
so listen up folks stop wasting time
going to the post office and start going
to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with my promo code
h3 you get a special offer that includes
four-week trial plus free postage
and a digital skill low long-term
commitment or contracts just go to
stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in h3 that's
stamps.com
promo code h3 thank you so much thank
you stamps.com
it ended wow that was fast 30 minutes
yeah
well we have dude i'm telling you we
have a lot of good stuff here um
yeah you should be calling in soon so
maybe we should set that up really
well it's uh it's one o'clock oh my
goodness
time is flying by when you're having fun
when you're getting sued
real quick um since we're in a little
bit
of a lull uh we got a 100 dollar super
chat
thank you bill uh to read that out uh
finally finishing
my thesis for my mfa and i can see these
lives again i want to celebrate by
donating towards you guys so you can all
treat yourself
uh for your legal funds against jake
soyboy paul
not my words jake soyboy paul not my
word this is not
uh the opinion of the exactly no no no
no no
jake paul is uh definitely not
a soy man the opinions of our viewers
are
their own jake paul is definitely not
not gonna say it don't lie
but thank you thank you so much and
congratulations on finishing your uh
mfa that's like master of fine arts i
love that
hello little [ __ ] name
[Applause]
jake paul with the known with soybeans
i got your hat i drink soy milk i like
soy milk actually no i don't i drink
almond milk now
right almond is the way to go soy milk's
fine though right
i just like almond milk better frankly i
don't like the oat milk i gotta tell you
you like oat milk no i'm saying i don't
exactly zach just asked if we do those
oh you do oat
you know love oat milk oh almond for me
is just the way to go although i hear
almonds really bad like it uses a lot of
water
so it's growing almonds specifically
uses tons of water so how does the
almond milk get made then
uh i'm sure i guess that probably has a
ton of water too
but specific cultivating almonds uses a
ton of water yeah
but almond milk i know this is really
interesting content guys
oh my milk is really cheap people really
like oat milk in the chat
oh yeah people are all about it i just i
honestly gotta check it out
i never tried it vanilla oat milk from
whole foods
[Music]
are you drinking flavored zack so if you
put in my coffee
wow if you drink oat milk are you
officially a soy boy like that's
literally no there's no no soy milk is
for soy
soy boys yeah no soy in the oatmeal
because i don't know if this is
i don't i doubt it's true but they the
whole there's like this weird thing
about like oh you drink so much soy that
you have like
tits because apparently it has like
estrogen i don't really think that's
true though yeah
it's it's a whole yeah it's not there is
estrogen in it but it's plant estrogen
it doesn't actually it doesn't do
anything yeah i'm not gonna like turn
you into a woman yeah it doesn't
do that yeah okay
uh fascinating stuff
it was fascinating yeah um so jake
speaking of jake paul who was a friend
of the show one that we really like you
you know
jake paul great guy not a soy boy fan of
the show
um definitely not
shout out to his family definitely not
accused of
that's not
you're tripping
okay the president's on hold by the way
he is yes okay bring him on president
the president we can't keep the
president waiting okay all right stand
by i'll bring on the president i have to
pee but i'll hold it for the president
yeah
hold on hold off on the music he's not
here yet hold off on the music the
president's not here yet
we we just give me one sec
so um i do i wonder greatly what was
discussed on that call
and why was jake paul even caught you
know how did that get set up
um trump is actually on triller who you
know software we love
great program great software uh
you know donald trump he's been banned
on every
media platform except trailer apparently
and this is
actually folks um
a real post from his trailer account
i thought this was a gag but they
actually he actually posted this
[Applause]
[Music]
oh we can't play this music
people are waiting for you so it looks
like trump doing all this stuff
joe biden's sleeping it's like dude you
lost what do you want to do i mean
he's pregnant and you're not this looks
like it was a campaign ad
this might have been posted this is a
priority dad yeah this is prior
and all inspired no badly oh so they
like put it together with the sleepy
biden exactly also just sleepy joe can
you be any more delusional yeah
well all these in retrospect are so
funny because it's like
yeah he beat you while like just
sleeping in like that's how easy it was
that's how easy it was let's be honest
trump wasn't the oh we have the
president we could just talk correctly
we can talk directly to him he is right
here wow what an honor to have you
joined by the president again
ethan elliot can you hear me yeah
baron is this on is this like okay we
can hear you mr president we can't hear
you
mr president so great to be back on your
show it's such an
honor for you to have me on again the
first appearance it broke
all the internet records that you've
ever had which is absolutely fantastic
everything i touch turns to gold it
turns to gold so i'm very excited to be
on and uh you guys are big social media
people
and i want to announce i have a uh
what's called a blog
i invented something called a blog and
it's very big now you go to my website
and you do slash desk and that's my new
blog you can be there
i'm sorry i'm sorry what is the address
uh
well the i don't know does anyone know
kelly what's the complaint address
okay they're gonna check they're going
to check but if you do slash desk
then you everything i say is there okay
interesting
twitter slash desk okay well first of
all uh
donald thank you for joining us how is
life you know it's been a
it's been a minute uh you're out of
office um
how was life down at mar-a-lago just
checking in a little bit
well it's absolutely fantastic we built
a replica of the press room
here of course there's a seal has a big
red tea like my tie like my tie this is
the room where the fake news
used to ask me a lot of fake news
questions but now i'm in charge
because i'm the real news president and
i'll be back very soon believe me
believe me but everything's great i golf
every day i have a cheeseburger every
day i feel absolutely fantastic
all the bigwigs uh come down to visit me
so i had ted cruz here
i had ted cruz here you know lionted
right like did you did you when you guys
were enjoying dinner did you say a
comment on his wife's appearance or was
that not disgusting absolutely
absolutely he takes it so well i mean
it's just you just can't help to kick
this guy he's such a loser
he's such a loser your wife's ugly he's
like yes sir yes sir
yes sir you know he just goes with
whatever i say
and it's tremendous and that's really
interesting to know yeah
because during the campaign you had
famously called his wife ugly you had
said his dad was like killed
jfk yeah his dad did kill jfk you know
i think it's great he just goes along
with it he just goes i could say pretty
much anything
i could say he kidnapped the lindbergh
baby
it's amazing they don't really seem to
care it is amazing
listen i mean can i say can i say uh ask
kisser on your show is that okay
oh you can say whatever you want mr
president oh we don't have any rules no
fcc okay well what an ass kisser this
guy is my god
it's really incredible he's so slimy
he's so slimy he just kind of slithered
away at the end of dinner i actually
gave him a bill for dinner
there you go ted you're paying for both
of us bro
[Laughter]
now did you guys compare hand size i
know you got criticized for having small
hands did you
did i noticed the photo his hands looked
kind of small his
let me tell you something people give me
a hard time look at these hands look at
these these are big heads these are
billionaire hands presidential hitch you
know what they say
big hands big gloves well for him he is
the tiniest
he's like those little toy hands he's a
little toy hats right do you ever see
those little
he literally has little toy hands it's
incredible
it's incredible so small and you know
what they say we have tiny hands
what did they say well you know what
they said little marco tried to say that
about me
because there's no complaints down there
very happy customers
very happy customers believe me believe
me even sturmy daniel said
wow i've never seen a shape like that
before and that's a compliment right
well i remember well i do recall her
describing that you had like a
big mushroom tip with a mushroom head
nice true bed the purple helmet club i'm
very proud of that i'm very proud of her
and fair skin i have fair skin down
right okay well fantastic i didn't
expect to discuss your penis today but
i'm happy to discuss whatever you want
i'm so happy to discuss my penis penis
you know what i mean no one has a penis
like my penis
believe me oh i believe you so let me
are you planning there's a lot of
questions about 2024
possibly running what do you think
people are saying maybe you'll be too
old by then
or you're very youthful i'm very
youthful i was the youngest president of
the history of presidents but i really
like this country what are you talking
about what are you talking about
i need young and divine because i'm a
stable genius and i have a very young
mind
yeah i have a very young mind and i have
very smart blood did you know that so my
blood isn't really aging
like sleepy jokes because he's like 100
years old a lot of people don't know
that
he's so old they discontinued his blood
type so he's not going to be around too
much longer
and i could step in at any time any time
i could come back in and i think 2024 is
right around the country
right around the corner and i would do a
tremendous job and listen
listen all likes you know all the cnn
msnbc
ratings way down i can help them if i
come back in the face band
you know the facebook ban which is
absolutely ludicrous it's sad it's sad i
can't
no one's no one can hear me i'm being
silenced that's true
oh yeah it is true it is true that's why
we're giving you a platform sir
thank you so much you're a true american
absolutely
well okay so what i really wanted to ask
you about here today
is that um i'll show it on the screen
here is that apparently
i know you're a very busy man but you
made time to call jake i got a lot of
time i'm really not doing anything too
yeah
okay i was trying to be nice
well you facetimed uh jake paul and i
was just curious
how that came to be well you know what
he just kept
sure sir president trump sir sir sir
could i talk to you sir sir it'll be
very impressive for my followers sir
and he said and he said it was at the
top of his list
at the top of his list and i thought you
know what who
am i to take away this kid's dream
and being able to check this off his
list so i faced time with him
i didn't realize i had a bear in the
cave it was a bad idea
oh no no right but we i was on my
private
trump jet which is an incredible jet no
one has a jet like my jet it's really an
incredible it's an amazing jet probably
i believe you should just like light it
down
yeah but we did it and he has it now and
he sees leverage
he calls it leverage they call it
leverage and he's leveraging it but i'm
leveraging it too because
i want to be part of the uh the paul
compound because they got a lot of
a lot of people there a lot of great
people him his brother not so much his
dad but you know
and so um what did you guys discuss on
the phone call
oh you know uh what's better kfc
or mcdonald's you know in a pinch what
wendy's do
you know what he made he made sure to
tell me he's not using any
steroids or anything like that to get
into shape
no performance enhancing drugs i was
like i believe you i don't even know why
you'd bring that up i didn't even ask
oh are you insinuating that he might be
juicing because he brought it up out of
nowhere well i'm not really a juice guy
i like diet soda and things like that
but you know he might be
he might be because he might have one
and you know those type of things and
they make the juice out of that
did he mention he's a big guy he's a big
he looks a little unusually big
i'm a big guy i'm six three and you know
he's like
right you know he's filling the whole
frame in the facetime
and what what was the impression you got
from talking to jake do you think he's
like a smart guy do you think he's an
interesting guy
so when you compare to a lot of people i
know i mean compared to don and eric
he's like a genius right
right you know he seems he seems very
smart about his
type of work i mean i would you know i
wouldn't replace him you know
at an important job in the well then
again i probably would i'd probably
put him in some secret you know like a
secretary of state or something oh jake
paul secretary of state
oh yeah because he knows a lot of people
he knows a lot of people
who know people are good secretaries of
state pretty high up there
did you did you discuss with him that
possibly maybe we could get you in the
ring to do a boxing match these are very
popular now
apparently people are making them i
actually did the whole thing with vince
mcmahon and the uh
you know the right experience yeah we
shaved his head we shaved his head
you know and i came close i could have
lost my hair but we shaved vince
mcmahon's head and did you know some of
that is choreographed did you know that
did you know that i just found that out
i thought it was all real
yeah i no i didn't know that actually
i'm just finding that out right now for
me i learned that i learned that
those guys really juice believe me they
were there's like a table in the back
room
when i was on it was just like a
smorgasbord of stuff well could
you get could we get you in the ring
today possibly like who who would be a
good match-up for you would you fight
jake paul
uh yeah sure i'd take that kid in like
five minutes
all right all right he wouldn't know it
hit him you have to remember i'm six
three and i'm very very strong i'm
probably the strongest president in the
history of france
right i mean very very strong and no one
hits a ball the way i had a ball have
you seen some of my golf shots i have a
i have a tremendous body and i have a
lot of center weight a lot of stuff
yeah we we noticed actually i've noticed
you have quite a dump truck as the kids
say
i've seen it yeah and the women the
women love that they love that they love
big butts on men
right i got a good one i gotta get
melania who i haven't seen in quite a
while but she's
supposed to know this where's melania
no she likes to play hide and seek here
at mar-a-lago
she's really good at it because
sometimes she's gone four and five days
at a time and then she pops up in
another country
you know what i mean she's incredible
though is she amazing she speaks six
languages
one of them isn't english unfortunately
i always wanted to ask you you know her
campaign as the first lady was be
best against bowling the best and i
would say that was just so ironic
because
i mean not to call you a bully sir but
you did have strong
uh uh you know confrontational words
with a lot of people so i thought it was
somewhat ironic
that her campaign was be best well you
know what
be best wasn't just about internet
bullying which i'm probably the best at
uh it's also about being the best person
that you can be
you know what i mean but if you're a
loser i'm gonna call you out i'm gonna
tell you
right you know what i mean and that's
just being honest that's just
you're doing the person a favor being
honest with you if you know what i'm
talking about
you know did melania ever once try to be
like you know mr president
i'm doing the best thing maybe you could
tone it down on twitter
i don't really listen to her when she
talks
you know and it's hard to understand her
it's hard to understand it's a lot of
clicking and popping that you're talking
i just give her money she disappears
comes back with a nice handbag
yeah okay well um hmm
well i'm very endless i'm very happy to
hear from you it's just i find it's such
a shame that you've been silenced as you
say because you know
we just we miss your tweets we miss
seeing you in the white house
i'm very sad for example to see that the
kovit cases are going down and that
people are getting vaccinated i know
that's because of me that's the warp
speed program that i i created that's
that's me i did that i did that
because you remember i said i'd like
everything opened by easter and we
pretty much were and we pretty much
and i was a year ahead of everyone you
see that because i'm a stable genius and
i'm always ahead of everybody
do you believe people should be wearing
masks by the way well you know if you
want to
if you don't want to it's fine i mean
halloween's probably the ideal time to
do that
right right right and not because like
the panda the cdc says we should be
wearing masks it's more about just if
you want to celebrate
celebrate all right i mean you know if
it's a good look you could wear you know
for me i'm just not a masked guy
in general you know what i'm saying but
like mike pence he looks good in a mask
you know what i mean anything to cover
his
mouth is that's what i like you know but
if you want to wear it wear it if you
want to get vaccinated get vaccinated if
you don't want to get vaccinated
who cares right i get vaccinated i did
it in secret and everyone's like why'd
you do it in secret because i
didn't want anyone to know but now they
know so go ahead and get vaccinated if
you want to but if you don't want don't
do do it right
freedom freedom like mel gibson said at
the end of braveheart
right freedom thank you thank you thank
you
well wow you must have a big crowd at
the studio you've been the biggest crowd
50 60 000 people well mr president it's
been
uh of course a great honor to have you
calling absolutely and i do want to
mention i'm glad you brought up you know
uh
jake paul i i think what happened the
other day at that blm march was very
unfortunate all he did was take some
guy's hat and now he has to fight some
guy
he turns out to be a professional boxer
which was totally rigged from the
beginning
i have to tell you look all set up to me
oh you think that the
jake paul versus ben askren fight was
rigged
oh absolutely absolutely right
absolutely
he he he didn't win did he didn't win
did he
and do you think well just to correct
you sir that wasn't a black lives matter
march some people might find that
offensive it was just uh
they were just i was just people yeah
you know i just figured
it's a group of black people it's just a
margin
and i love the black people listen i
love the black people they're tremendous
people fantastic people
great people there's none of them here
in west palm but i'm sure you know in
d.c
well um well you know i'd love to have
you back again to comment on the ongoing
um
issues oh you know what i'm sorry to
keep you i just have so many questions
for you are you more of a maverick or a
jake pollard
right well you know i i like jake pauler
but the whole maverick thing with me
reminds me of john mccain and as i've
always said i like my war heroes who
don't get captured
you know what i'm saying right so i'm
gonna have to go with jake pauler yeah
but i do like
top gun and the sequel's coming out very
very soon
oh maverick and top gun right right
are you are you into boxing mr president
absolutely you remember one of my good
friends was uh don king
dun king great guy one of the biggest
promoters of all time and i had mike
tyson fight
at trump plaza many many times in
atlantic city
maybe a lot of money made me a lot of
but not enough to scave off the
bankruptcy but it made me already
sure that's a lot yeah that's a lot of
money for that
i'm sorry i just there's i there's one
famous video that we love to talk about
here of your son
don jr on instagram talking about his
algorithms being crushed
did you guys ever get any information
about the algorithms being crushed by
instagram or anything like that
well you know we negotiated with
algorithm and some other countries near
them and i thought everything was fine
with the algorithm and albania and some
of those other countries
so it's it's one they're wonderful
people they're hardworking people the
algorithm
okay oh i think you missed the well that
okay i won't
i get your drift i won't i won't ask a
follow-up for that one
all right well listen mr president it's
been an honor
thank you always always an honor for you
yeah always an honor
and you guys by the before i go how's
teddy fresh how's teddy fresh what a
great guy here
oh very good thank you mr president very
good uh how's it going
it's the best it's it's doing very very
well in the industry there's nothing
like it
it's nothing that's what i like to hear
that's how we did with the hats with the
maga hats it did very very well
is that a teddy fresh that you're
wearing ethan yes it is mr president
i like that oh thank you so much that
would look very good down here at
mar-a-lago maybe you could open a shop
inside of mar-a-lago oh thank you for
the opportunity interesting yeah
i think that would be very nice that
would show how hip how hip i am yeah
yeah well we'll talk we'll discuss that
we'll maybe we'll discuss that
thank you so much again and thank you
have a tremendous
oh and i forgot i got you to something
because you do i got you your own
your own presidential pardon oh
wow yes does that work just in case you
did it
justin this will cover all federal
crimes i can't help you on a state level
i know you're in california right you
know with that guy from
whatever his name is but uh this will
get you any federal crimes i could cover
you you know what i mean
thank you we're gonna ship that right
over to you if you can send me the money
on the
venmo we'll get the shipping you have to
pay for it oh that's yeah
absolutely what do you think i'm doing
for free right no i did actually but
okay we'll figure it out generally gifts
you don't have to pay for it
is the thing well yeah but that's okay
exactly
all right you do tremendous speaking
with you
i'm gonna have my third lunch that's
what i call it
that sounds good really incredible it's
gonna be delicious it's gonna be all
right
mr president take care we love you all
right everybody bye-bye
thank you so much how do i turn this off
i just turned this
oh oh there you go okay you figured it
out wow
wow what a i mean the president calling
into the h3 podcast
incredible unbelievable we got our own
pardon
yeah i wonder how much he wants for it
though because i'm kind of strapped with
the lobby they go for like 50
000 or something like that pardons for
50 grand this is pretty cheap
that's a good deal i wish it worked on
lawsuits
you might babe maura for it in that case
um well you know what i should have
asked him if he talked to jake paul
about dropping the lawsuit
right you know can you get him back on
the phone
i'm kidding i love that that donald
trump man
love him it's really cool of him to make
time for our podcast you know
um we were talking about uh legend right
you know i do miss trump in the way that
like he's just so entertaining
absolutely so entertaining
he's a showman just not as president no
not so presidential
yeah 69.
um so we have you know we have white
clock gabe calling in at two
until then i have so much fun stuff to
talk about one being
okay last christmas
we had a secret santa in which ian
gifted a cursed cosby doll
right to me and
we've been secretly tracking
the whereabouts of this cursed uh cosby
doll
now um
zach reese well i'll just let play it i
mean this thing has switched hands
this curse has been transferred so many
times starting with by the way
dan leaving it in the [ __ ] basement
and i was like dan you can't leave this
[ __ ] here he goes oh it doesn't fit in
my car i was like really [ __ ] it
doesn't fit in your car you're gonna
leave that here
so it's changed hands so many times and
it's all been documented
so i'd like to present you guys today
the path of the cursed cosby doll
and i think you guys are going to enjoy
this a lot it ends up
well i won't spoil the surprise but you
guys are not going to want to miss this
oh my god
i'm a cosby kid oh no
put it back it's cursed this thing is so
cursed bro
this was described to me as a haunted
baby cradle i can't bring that into my
[ __ ] house
that survived the fire in 1930
what the seller described it as unsolved
oh my god bro you really shouldn't have
brought that into my house disrespected
the [ __ ] out of you guys today he double
parked
he brought you up you really brought
this into my [ __ ] house
at least you gave it to dan and not me
[Music]
[Music]
so every time i come down here to
exercise
i feel his presence you know what i mean
it would be funny if i just left
it at ian's porch dude i mean like
why are we not going to deal with this
[ __ ] dan first of all left it in the
basement
which was a total dick move by the way
so maybe you're so you're accepting this
for me
and you're lifting the curse i'm
accepting it from you
thank you and zach hold it by the net
savage
all right guys bye guys
[Music]
destroy the child
[Music]
i'm handing this off to ian god bless
appreciate you
i've i'm so happy to see this again
i'm grinning under this mask can you
tell
all right all right man good luck thank
you i hope it's uh we get a good
reaction on
dan he deserves it
yeah it was like it wasn't like knocking
but it was like
i don't know what the [ __ ] i wanted to
get i don't know
oh my god
[Music]
well now we have to get rid of it yeah
what are we supposed to do
[Music]
play
now i just want to clarify do you want a
b b was holding on to it the whole time
it was in his trunk the doll and the
carriage for like five
months
[Laughter]
did you feel at any time the presence of
the curse
no but like every time i got in my car i
checked my back seat
because of chucky you didn't want to
make sure the cosby doll was there
yeah but we had debated like the actual
status of the curse right here because
it was technically a gift to dan right
uh this the stroller was for dan yes
right so the stroller was transferred to
dan via
the curse and then because it was the
gift
and then dan left it here in my basement
but technically the curse was still upon
dan dan would have to give it away to
transfer the curse
did that ever happen did dan did you
ever give it away or i think technically
you're still cursed by it
uh well i never let it enter my home is
the thing
so i feel like i may have sidestepped
the curtain uh by that
it is sitting in the garage of my
apartment building though i just left it
down there
oh so it's still like somewhat in my
position
bro i feel like if it didn't cross the
threshold i'm i'm okay
i think i'm in the clear okay i don't
feel i will see
you don't want ian's chair
[Music]
dan okay all right zach wants the chair
she's gonna get the chair
so wait so just to clarify yeah uh you
have the carriage in your garage dan but
the cosby doll is being transferred to
zach correct
so it's interesting that they've they've
kind of gone a different path
yeah they've they've diverged
we thought it was best to put them up
thank i mean thanks for bringing it up
what the [ __ ] is this the chair bro it's
all you baby
is your [ __ ] ass no no i didn't put
my ass on it
it's it's it's a fair deal bro i brought
the chair
you take the dog
i don't want it then i'm gonna roll down
that is so uncool i
bring the chair and leave the [ __ ]
doll i gotta burn some [ __ ] seats
bad voodoo in here man
[ __ ] can you stand out here [ __ ] dude
all right exactly you don't i don't want
i don't i don't want it you're seven
foot what what
what's the ghost going to do to your
world how tall you are i don't know
i was actually saying what was the sage
for zach
i don't want to
oh so you brought the sage out to give
to do like a voodoo
curse release on the to cleansing yeah
yeah
okay okay do you do a lot of cleansing
rituals
this to the toilet every morning
i gotcha you have that you wouldn't have
i don't want the chair
all right go go give to the neighbors
i'm not holding that [ __ ] back i don't
want the [ __ ] chair
who put you up as you guys see he's
safer i can't there's no winnings
why would you do this why i thought he
was doing it
but he really doesn't want to take the
chair bro there it was hong kong
oh zach you're definitely you're
attempting fate right there
yeah you guys i really thought he was
doing a bit he didn't want to take it
you guys are
[ __ ] up your neighbors are about to
get a good chance
of [ __ ] residence and you have
something to drink dude i just broke my
face i'm dying
out of here you'll be good man
all right brother
[Music]
did you take the chair zach yeah he's
sitting right now
comfortable as you love the care oh my
god okay
good after everything i'm glad you at
least enjoy it okay
um so what was your thoughts when you
saw the voodoo doll i think that
genuinely freaked you out right
well i met abe downstairs um and he was
like a little weird
there's something off about him yeah
okay i mean there's always something a
little off about him but this time you
know
definitely a little more than usual
coming from the guy who
times you cut out there what what'd you
say
i said coming from the guy who lit sage
six times
i'm sorry i want to bring good vibes
into
you know well let me finish the video
here i think there's something coming up
is this how do you get out yeah we're
from where oh
thank you see you buddy later later
oh you didn't end up leaving it
hold up let it play it's on your car oh
it just said it said the doll is on your
car did you know that zach
the doll is on your car have you used
your car since this was shot
no i think av left the doll on your car
you see zach you were playing checkers
while i was playing chess is that the
line
yo what are you going to do with the
doll it's on your car
look at them i start crying dude oh no
[Music]
you're very zach is very superstitious
so these things have a lot a big effect
on him
you're going to have to touch it like
there's nothing cursed about the doll
it's just a toy how do you feel abs card
is hold back how do you know nothing
happened how do i know
i mean it was it was a retail product
sold inside
why would you put that on my [ __ ] car
you know i did get cancelled after i
took that doll now i think about it
[Music]
why would you put on my [ __ ] car i'm
not taking that [ __ ] back
i've had that first [ __ ] [ __ ]
what why did you do that
it's time for you to bear the weight my
friend well hold on hold on
[ __ ] man you're coming to pick this up i
don't care where you're going like
you're a man now
you live alone no no you brought
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you you're coming to pick
that up
well is there is there any argument to
be made about like
abe has held the burden of this doll
for so long right five months and like
in the lord of the rings you guys are
best friends right our
friends i don't know the status of your
friendship to necessarily best but
that's just clearly not anymore but like
you remember how sam took the row
the ring he says let me lighten the load
could that be you zack can you lighten
the low share the load a little bit
no because the ring was something of
good and this is no
no it wasn't it was cursed it was just
like this i've never seen that rings all
right what oh the ring was a curse bruh
how could you get that wrong i just i
i've never got into that how the [ __ ]
have you never seen a lot of rings
i've never gotten into the middle earth
[ __ ] i i just the hobbit
you're in middle earth now moral of the
story i want to share my load with you
that's it
right
well zach can i suggest something you
could just get in your car and drive off
without you know touching it and then
right wherever
there shall be buried yeah but i just
don't want it in the same vicinity like
i just
that that's stuff can you go out zach
can you do me a favor can you go outside
and take a photo
if it's on your car still i want to know
someone took it yeah maybe someone took
it maybe it walked off on its own
right it could have can you go down
there and take a photo of your car
or if it's just outside of his front
door right now hey take this sage
i don't know my it's three it's three
stories down you want me to go walk
yes all right i'm really curious so
we'll check back in with zach
to see if the doll is still on his car
i'm very curious
maybe someone took it you know i mean
maybe someone was like hey
old uh crusty cosby doll oh no we
wouldn't want that maybe it'll pop back
up
so bad that there's a good chance no one
took it yeah i think it's still there
i genuinely do still think it's there
wow well that was fun that was a fun
adventure yeah
man that segment was so good ian we're
still getting
we're still getting uh foot goofs from
it
even almost half a year later
oh here's some fun stuff i wanted to
show you guys
uh we're in a new workshop for dan you
know
uh we're moving too soon and um
dan wanted a new setup so here's some
stuff we were looking at either
i don't think you've seen this so tell
me what you think something like this
baby
zero gravity workshop can i get it
fifth sixteen thousand it's only it's
only sixteen thousand dollars whoa
yeah that seems like totally reasonable
why would anyone want this
because i could command the show from
there just imagine how cool i would look
on the show when it cuts away and i'm
like you know i'm switching i'm doing
the audio i'm doing all kinds of stuff
for my from my station
you know my we've always had that when
ian was sick and he did the show from
bed
it almost looked like that right exactly
as a proof of concept well when i first
saw this i was like is this for
paraplegics or what but no these are
this is just people that want to
rock out and zero g apparently gravity
doesn't exist when you're laying down
according to them
yeah i don't understand that it's
definitely g but look they have a whole
they have got a whole collection of them
why is it called zero gravity
it's just you're just floating it's just
kidding
uh there's some really good ones here oh
my god
he's got a suit on and [ __ ] he's like
all right
what is this i was thinking it would be
might be funny to buy one oh this one's
only five thousand
yeah but this one's not as funny the
best ones coming up actually the one
that i really want
this is like the guys who operate drones
in afghanistan they're in there
we might need to get put on a vr goggle
headset
triple monitor i got the laptop off to
the side
this is some real end-of-life two
laptops look at that he's got a laptop
on each side
right like you could actually do the
show absolutely i could i think we
should get it
you know yeah it's gonna be but you know
it takes like 10 minutes to get out
we got them like damn when you got an
issue
[Laughter]
wait wait the one the one i actually
want is still coming up
yeah but like i feel like i used to play
everquest with people that actually were
like this was how they played right
probably
you know what i mean yeah same
this guy is totally flat
totally prone 100 what if we got two for
us and we did the show like that
well how you'd have to have a camera up
but then it wouldn't look that different
it would just be a little weird well
you'll have one white shark that shows
well this one's seven thousand dollars
so how much was the gatsby it was like
i won them all gatsby was only like four
grand so this is only twice as expensive
of a goof and i just don't know if it's
got
oh it has wheels so i could wheel your
ass around yeah exactly
interesting my god
whoa whoa he's like he's like he's
upside down his hair is lowered
upside down that that cannot be
comfortable
like oh my god we've totally inverted
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's basically just when my dad used
to like be on his laptop at home
can you imagine a recliner that's
basically what it was
right can you imagine we delivered this
to your parents house
and saw your dad in this
it's so uh it's like a desk right you
take some notes
that is a huge task what the [ __ ]
like what are you even gonna do with the
desk you can't put it right you can't
put anything on what he's putting it
keeps falling off on him
they need zero g um desk like notebook
holders and pen holders
right some sort of uh magnetic thing to
hold your stuff from there this can't
make them look so crazy like this huge
arm goes like 10 feet up in the air
it's like a little uh gallow you could
also hang yourself from it if you
uh died too many times in every quest
right
whoa whoa this looks serious that's a
thick boy
look at that arm oh my god helicopter
this one's ready to take off
it can also fly
there's a laptop on the side how do you
use the mouse what are you gonna even do
with that yeah
right you there's no way you could use
it how do you use a mouse i think you'd
have to like
mount a trackball or something so
you can't use a normal mouse yeah right
um this one you could do pull-ups
work out although that seems like the
antithesis of the zero g
right you're not buying zero g
workstations to do pull-ups i can't
believe they have so many they have so
many and we still haven't gotten to my
favorite
there's one that there's one that's far
and away the best one
yeah it's it's got to be coming up man
they
oh
[Laughter]
which is your favorite not this one
still it's still it's still coming up
this one look he looks like a artillery
he looks like he's ready to shoot some
shells off
he's banning the guns what kind of jobs
are these people gonna do
like right yo what is this one
this one looks like a gyro where you
could roll off
why are the bars got to be so intense
whoa whoa i don't even that's like that
one that's like a super villain
set up
how do we oh this one's pretty basic
only 3 000.
there it is that's the one i love so
this one is
this one is got a gyroscope it it
rotates i could spin
it yes there's a video of it if you guys
want to show upside down
i don't know if it goes fully upside
down but it does like i could win
we need to get you like a whole harness
so you can do it upside down
here there's a video of it right uh yeah
i think it's a
here oh my god here can i play this
music i wonder
uh it's probably royalty free but i'll
mute it just 77
likes all the smoke yeah so by the way
this video was uploaded 2010 so they
haven't upgraded their tech recently
but here is the gyro in action oh wow he
goes up
the perfect height he's so
quick look how fast
i would love to test the limit of how
far you can rotate
bro why do you want to sit like that oh
my god
i'm perfectly fine i'm getting upright
you cut to den and you just see
your feet basically look how the monitor
yeah you just see dad's feet
look how the monitors rotate because you
can't move your head anymore
i just don't understand the need
you stretch your body look how massive
this thing is i'm kind of surprised that
only oh this thing is like 16 grand
right
this one is very expensive please tell
me that it goes upside down
uh that's a good question if it goes all
the way around uh they don't do it in
this demo but
it didn't really look like there was
anything to stop it here it looks like
you see how long it takes to get out
ergo quest
i wonder if they're still in business
you should try calling them yeah zach or
somebody try calling them just to see
like hey
are you guys still in business can we
get one of these i think
their website's still up i mean they're
in business
i'm not trying to prank call them i'm
just genuine we should get it
this one yeah 17 000 hilo i'm being sued
i can't afford this
it depends if this one goes upside down
i think it's worth it
oh so maybe call and ask if it goes
upside down
they will not advise you to let it go
all the way i'm not asking for their
advice
yeah i'm not asking for anyone's advice
yeah let me know i'm already i'm on the
phone okay yeah just it's called the
zero gravity workshop 10 let me know
uh i mean we could settle for the
cheaper ones
if we have yeah i mean come on i mean a
lot of those were epic
that was just that one was my personal
favorite one i'm actually afraid as if
if jake paul wins the lawsuit he's going
to get
the zero gravity oh no oh god imagine if
he took the cat speed
pretty fine and the gas they're going to
impound my tragic
repo guy comes from the gatsby let's
read the specs here we've got a recliner
i think it's a good investment
oh it's a good investment okay yeah you
know for the content
i appreciate the value over time yeah
ah there's more oh yeah this one's
pretty uh base it doesn't have wheels i
can't wheel his ass around
it's like they're always trying to make
it look good for your living room
right yeah good furniture for the living
room this one's a dental uh
chair pretend you're at the dentist
while you game
look at this one dude
why do you need this it's like a bowflex
uh bullflex world why is it gonna be
like a giant square
and it's almost like i do you guys still
carry the zero gravity chair
oh workstation we've got ab on the phone
with them now
okay and does that go completely upside
down getting the details
uh yeah you can go completely oh stop
don't don't
close your mic maybe yeah i don't want
to
put him on so uh av will get back to us
on
it sounds like possibly it does though
he made it sound like that was a yes
um very interesting that's [ __ ] epic
if it does so i'm gonna have to be
dropping 17 grand
well you don't have to well we have a
lot of space in the office too i mean
damn i'd love to get your asses
down to the show we could get a payment
plan
whatever it takes nobody gets you alone
with your big suit
really just show them what it's for look
this is essential to our business zero
gravity
maybe the government will give us
because hard times you know we can get
like a government loan
because it's essential i i asked for
permission
oh you you did yeah and they said
yeah he said it was fine but we didn't
really hear anything anyway but what did
he say
um he said it doesn't do a complete it
doesn't do a complete one it doesn't do
a complete circle
they're okay still in business man
that's amazing but you can get upside
down
like it has a it has a tilt you said it
has a tilt forward but depending on what
equipment you have attached
yeah the battery it probably matters to
the balance and everything no i want to
know
what degree i know it doesn't go like a
full circle
what degree does it tilt can you get him
back on the phone
just like to what because this is a big
investment so i want to know
like what degree is dan's head going to
be yeah
you know
[Music]
if we buy this thing
y'all if we buy this y'all better not
let me go bankrupt
well with the kind of content you would
be creating with that you think we've
been how could you
honey yeah exactly with seeing dan's
feet instead of his face
yeah right careful
back we don't want we don't want me on
wiki feet again very true
uh zach is back from his car did you get
any photos what's the status out there
well i went down there and there was
nothing on the car oh
oh so interesting maybe
were you trolling or uh because zack
says there was no doll on the car
which car did you take with you what do
you mean what car
he only has one car i only have one car
did you just put it on some random
stranger's car maybe
i hope not no that was that car did you
put it on
you have a white car in a black car i
don't have a [ __ ] white car
who's a white car what off two cars what
zack don't make me don't make me do this
to you right now you don't you don't
have a white [ __ ] camaro
i was imagining us in a white camaro is
it it's not mine
oh whose car is it did you steal it it's
not even part way well
that's not even parked here what so
you're trying to make me seem [ __ ]
crazy like that
no no you're not crazy that that car is
not parked here though
oh okay this is my dad that's my dad's
car so you put it on some other random
person's uh
you put on his dad's car at me no no i'm
just asking which car he took with them
because no i put on his car i took my
black car
okay yeah zach made it seem like he had
two cars but i guess it was his dad so
which car did you put the
doll on his ex car
it's all there so so the doll found a
new victim
it's kind of a happy ending right so is
the curse lifted
i think so i think the doll decided to
to i think a new cycle has started yeah
a new cycle started which is out of our
hands
there you go happy ending god bless and
good luck to whoever's got that
yeah where did that all end up man i i
do want to thank you for the new chair
um and if i may say i would like to
apologize for any uh drama
or anything um that might
have come from it right um i feel like i
learned a lot
from the situation right and um i'd like
to apologize to you ab
um for being baby-brained when i should
be a man hi yeah i'm curious what's the
tilt about this
is it yes no i'm just calling on behalf
of my boss he wants to know if it will
is it like a 90 degree tilt or
right
for the yeah the 4a
or the the workstation 5. either of
those two
what's that what were you saying oh they
hung up on me
why they dude these [ __ ] about
to sell one of these i think they think
you were trolling
i'm not trolling i'm literally they have
to make the first sale they've had in 10
years
all right zach they they heard your
apology what were you saying uh
yeah go ahead zach you were apologizing
for the chair fiasco
[Laughter]
zach was saying that was really
emotional and he was saying sorry to you
maybe
you're such an [ __ ] bro
i'm doing my job i did ask him to call
them he was on the phone
you did decide to start apologizing when
he was on the phone
oh zach do you want to take another
crack at the apology or no
yeah this will be the third time because
he already apologized on the last
episode
yeah the last episode zach made a big
apology yeah it was like this whole
break here yeah but zach you know zach
got a lot of heat in the comments for
the way he handled the chair fiasco
people were very critical of sweet young
zach and zach was feeling very hurt he's
feeling very offended
and just uh maybe well zach maybe i'll
let you speak for yourself on that
um so before i was rudely interrupted
um i would like to apologize to abe
for being baby brained i was being baby
brain when i should really be joker
brain
hold on they're calling back what
no i'm just [ __ ] with you go ahead
i'm sorry the second one wasn't as funny
you know anyway anyways
i'm gonna move forward from this okay
take a breath hold on take a breath this
is important re-center yourself
maybe some stage a b thank you but
let's let zach have his moment let me
take a breath hold on
take a breath this is important yeah oh
he took the corpse breath you hear that
yeah of course
that corpse breath exact breath let's
get it trendy
back breath i'd like to apologize uh to
you ethan and ela for being uh
because i i do represent the show as
well
uh you know and you know i want to be
one of your employees i have to show you
know that i'm mature enough and
don't do stupid things like that so um
i do apologize to you guys oh no need to
apologize to me
i mean who's entertaining right and
uh i'm learning from this and um
i will move forward from this and i will
be joker brandon not baby brand
okay so i'm hoping the fans can accept
zach's heartfelt apology
they were very upset about the way he he
handled the chair situation
and i hope we can just learn and move on
amicably as friends where is my apology
i apologize for him he was apartheid to
you oh okay i'm sorry maybe i missed
are you not going to apologize did you
apologize to the fans
i'd like to apologize well i guess one
more time i'd like to apologize to
the h3 community and the fans uh
i was being immature and i was being
stupid and right um
i'm gonna grow from this
peace and love peace and love wow zap
what an apology
so mature the man is just full of uh
insight today incredible
absolutely fantastic
well we got white cloth gabe coming up
here pretty soon um
there was a um
i didn't totally touch on the wikifeed
thing but
i wanted to say that everyone else got
booted off i don't think i didn't say
that right
no i don't think we did cover that
wikifeet the admins called the whole
[ __ ] thing
because zach abe dan even moses
and bobby lee are all gone they're all
gone they're all gone and
only from the page or from the top
rating
top rating i don't know if their pages
are still here let me see no i think the
pages
well at least for well bobby and myself
yeah bobby's place well bobby lee kind
of [ __ ] himself because he
his audience were trying to step to me
really and i think he got i'm not a foot
model yeah it looks like he got the ire
of the
he caught some uh he caught these arms
bro i don't even think about my feet
this is this is the [ __ ]
that's actually on wikipedia bro
[Laughter]
damn what the [ __ ] anyway um
there was a post of being like yo let's
get bobby number one and people are like
nah doug
so i think he got he caught these hands
as they say he caught these feet
and so now i am alone in the wow
so that's good i mean it's nice to be to
see that our tribe is unified like you
know
after all the war so lonely now no it
feels great i don't want anything
they're all by yourself
no it's just right where i should be
it's not lonely at all
i like solitude when it comes to feet
rating
so that's kind of a good news i love
that you're like in full character
now at the top yeah i decided whenever
i'm in costume i'm gonna put my feet up
yeah that's pretty i think
so that you like this one that's my shot
that's a great picture yeah
exactly and every time i'm an outfit
i'll get a new update
good photo um
i still wish i was at a seven it does
hurt my feelings that people really came
here and
you know but i just noticed i wanted to
smell feet there's a new contender
neil link a link rav rat and link is up
here oh what
when did that happen i don't know it's a
new development i like link so i'm not
going to [ __ ] on him right oh 110
pictures dude he has loyal foot soldiers
let me take a look see oh god link can
you [ __ ] have some shame please bro
this is basically pornography i mean
dude
please have some shame for you have some
of class
this is just this is just vile
this is a this he's supposed to be like
a nice christian family man and here he
is making pornography
on youtube you know what i mean look at
this
sheesh titties okay well whatever
no hate to link you know as long as you
don't get any closer to me
if he gets any closer we're gonna have a
problem
anyway uh white clock gabe should be
calling in here yeah he's uh
is he ready to go uh he's in the waiting
room there's a
there's a name okay ella's going to the
back hey it's friday baby
[ __ ] so yeah maybe set it up a little
bit
so white cloth gabe do you guys have um
here let me
watch uh where's white club gabe segment
here hang on what's up here
white club gabe now you guys know i'm a
i'm a huge fan of white claw gabe
um he's got some viral hits we've
watched him many times on this show but
his account has been absolutely blowing
up recently
like this one here let me just show you
some of the views he's been getting
um here let's see
this one is 700 000. this one is 1.5
million what do you got to say gabe
something's big is going to happen yeah
me and my boy ted baby
stay tuned baby [ __ ] baby [ __ ] fried
chicken wednesday baby
[ __ ] baby yeah take a bite fried chicken
baby [ __ ]
yes sir i have so many questions for him
yeah fried chicken wednesday baby i'm
super curious about like his living
situation
uh who he lives with what he does for
work
also he seems pretty like very pimped
out like rich she's always
pretty successful yeah successful in his
own right certainly
happy cinco de mayo baby yeah shout out
to the mexicano baby [ __ ] yeah
baby cerveza cerveza baby
[ __ ] yeah survey so you know he's up to
his all he's killing it on tick tock
um let me see some of his other hits
oh wow this one has six million you guys
whoa
this is like mega viral it's friday baby
[ __ ]
yeah it's the weekend baby [ __ ] this one
yeah
friday baby [ __ ] [ __ ] the weekend
last week oh my god wow
it's friday baby [ __ ] yeah it's the
weekend baby [ __ ]
oh it's mango flavor friday baby [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i saw in a lot of the other ones he's
holding a lime one though so and we i
got the limelight this one's
lime yeah there you go yeah good call
well anyway
and for those of you don't know what
club gabe that's pretty much the
scope of his content
play him some sound bites zach to just
kind of pepper the audience so they hey
it's friday baby yeah so you guys
know friday baby yeah let's bring in the
man himself
gabe friday maybe a second to set it up
here's another one with two million
views yeah the [ __ ] icy lemon baby
i'm just giving it a try it's not bad i
love iced tea i see lemon baby [ __ ]
white cross baby [ __ ] and this is what
it looks like the color if you pour in
the glass
it's almost like beer [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
almost
yeah white claw iced tea lemon baby [ __ ]
yeah try it it's not bad baby [ __ ] so
you know interestingly there's been all
kinds of memes now
uh oh there i see gabe himself gabe you
can you hear me it says connecting to
audio
he's still connecting oh i think he's
connected now
gay dave can you hear us what's going on
baby it's friday baby
it's friday yeah baby
friday yeah [ __ ] what are you doing
today it's friday what do we got planned
well i'm in miami i just went to the
beach i had lunch
you know i'm just enjoying my time right
now
are you loving life you've you are big
you're big time now dude
how are you loving the fame it's good
right now baby it's this is just like um
it's just like
appetizers wait till the the main course
comes
can you can you give me a little can you
give me a little bit of a
of a hint at what's the main course
going to be
well my main course is probably you know
some sponsors maybe if somebody wants to
um
be you know in a television shoot or
maybe in a major movie [ __ ]
that maybe you know
the big hollywood would come get me [ __ ]
yeah plug baby um well i have one idea
for someone who should be sponsoring you
right
oh i don't know why haven't they tried
there's so much um like white cars me
drinking the car everybody's buying it
and i don't know
why white cloud doesn't notice me
anything you know i got like yeah
yeah so gabe white claw has never
reached out to you
ah how do you feel about that well
i can't chase white club white claw has
to come to me right
hard to get yeah if i talk to me
i'll take it if not we need to we need
to start a movement
for white white white claw
sponsor gabe let's get that
trending
let me ask you this would you accept
payment and white clubs or do you want
money
uh i want some money yeah you want money
for sure
for sure for sure that makes sense
about helping them with their business
they have to pay me i'm helping them
you know bring the white car their
business you know having people buy
whacker
you know because of me you know i'm the
one that i'm the one that
jim you know promoting the white coat
with my ears me he's like hey white
hugging drinking the white cloud doing a
video
saying [ __ ] yeah people fighting
you know i wouldn't have this white claw
here today if it wasn't for you i'll
tell you that right now and i'll tell
that to white cloth they're watching
um this is all because of you gabe
oh yeah thanks do you love white claws
i love it it's like it's it has a
smoother taste it's not like beer or
anything it's like a hybrid of beer you
know it doesn't have that
really that alcohol tastes just like not
like truly or that um
that travis scott brand right it's your
favorite drink
i like it it's it's almost like soda
itself just
i can barely taste the alcohol that's
why i like white claws
right do you get [ __ ] up when you
drink white cloud you get super drunk
well if i once i get to the five or six
i'm level
[ __ ] yeah
yeah i think we should by the way what's
the flavor i have natural lime is that a
good flavor oh i love natural
that's my favorite flavor would you have
one baby oh good
do you have a do you have a white claw
with you there i'm not with me right now
well i'm gonna crack i'm gonna crack one
open and do a cheers to you
you know what's interesting gabe i've
never tasted a white cloth this is my
first time i wanted to do it with you
here today all right baby yeah
thanks thanks for trying to work
cheers to you bud i'm gonna i'm gonna
give you a review as i drink this
cheers baby that's good cheers baby
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah baby it's good yeah
[ __ ] white car baby [ __ ] it's friday
baby huh
it's good [ __ ] it's friday baby
[ __ ] yeah baby
[Laughter]
what's today gabe friday baby [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah it's friday huh oh it could say
black friday to do some shopping [ __ ]
worth [ __ ] school dude
[ __ ] work black friday school yeah baby
what do you do for work because it seems
like you're pretty blinged out dude
you've
eaten my steaks i do
aspiring work you know like acting and
stuff you know
just free freelancing like doing cameos
and
you know doing some merch right now oh
you're a cameo
yeah oh that's fantastic i'd love to
promote your cameo what is your cameo
well i do cameos like happy birthday or
do like i gotta sometimes i gotta roast
people like eight you're fat and ugly
and all that stuff oh you roast people
oh interesting congratulate them for you
know they make it through graduation
that's simple stuff like that oh if you
guys want to find white cloth gabe on
cameo it's just white cloth game
you have five stars dude that's awesome
perfect rating
let's go no one has ever been
disappointed uh with your
with your uh cameos would could you
roast me right now and give me like if i
ordered a cameo from you saying roast me
uh gross i'd say you're fat and ugly
you're lazy
i kind of think oh yeah [ __ ] yeah
baby thank you i just got a free roast
session from
the white clock game cheers buddy all
right baby
cheers [ __ ]
now can i ask you something that is a
little bit personal i'm sorry for asking
one of my friends trisha she thinks you
have tourette's and i don't
because of the way you always think [ __ ]
you don't have
you have tourette's by the way i have
tourette yeah
the rats is different is like you you're
just you can't control your um
anger you know you keep saying yeah one
more time you know
i just swear on the video because i get
my views up because
they want yeah
people love the [ __ ] it's just fun right
yeah like i re
redefine the word [ __ ] [ __ ] meaning like
slang
yeah you say you redefined the word [ __ ]
that's right [ __ ] baby have to have a
[ __ ] weekend
or instead of pair and you say [ __ ] that
counsel hilarious
wow dude i'm so happy that you're
killing it you've got your cameo popping
you're i saw you been treating your
friends and family to dinners that's
really nice you're the man baby
oh yeah i'm the big man you know other
you can't find people like that you know
like other
other people they like if you're in a
group of people they
they like either pay separate bill or
everybody chips and you can't find
people that could
you know just pick up the bill for like
six or seven days yeah i'm true
getting a lot of money that's true huh
you know you know my friends and family
are happy
my fans are happy you know you're like
wow i got i got my
great experience with white cloud gabe
you know or uh white clock gabe's the
man baby huh
oh right yeah who do you keep looking at
gabe who's in the room with you
oh somebody somebody showing me
something on the phone okay oh really
can i see who it is
is it one of your what's going on ethan
oh hey
i've seen you in um i've seen you in his
tick tocks what's your guys's
relationship
so he's my uh uncle he's uh
i help him with all his tick tocks and
that kind of stuff oh
legend what's your name dude i'm nick
nick nice to meet you
nick nick oh you're nick nick do you
like white claw
nice oh yes i do the man
we have a lot of good things cooking up
and uh we're doing his merch line so
when it comes time
what's the merch going to say
our chicken wednesday steaks um steak
like saturday or
[ __ ] monday kind of thing yeah [ __ ] baby
i would i would buy merch that said
it's i deserve fried chicken something
like that
yeah i deserve fried chicken fried
chicken hey gabe
you know that ethan quotes you basically
every weekend now
whenever he wants to eat like a cheat
meal it's like i deserve this [ __ ]
yeah i deserve it yeah you work hard you
deserve it baby
thank you gabe finally someone who
understands that about me um
so do you live with um what's your
living situation do you live with
uh uncle gabe with uncle gabe yeah do
you guys all live together
yeah we uh we all live together with my
family and all that stuff
wow what a big happy family um
nick the third you know we're all living
like a like a a bunch like a roommate
bunch
we go everywhere we travel um us and our
whole family we do everything together
so you know my dad's an actor
and gabe used to do stand-in work for
him in the 90s so gabe's like a
sag actor and he's worked so many jobs
and now it's his time to like
really shine and show the world who he
is and how funny he is and all that kind
of stuff
wow you know even in the 90s i always
try
wanting to be an actor you do all the
stuff gabe's humble but gabe's uh
gabe's a legit sag actor he's done
almost any any line of work you know
he's done uber
mcdonald's all that stuff so for now to
like really be shining it's like a
it's an incredible thing for him he
deserves it he deserves it oh yeah
oh yeah baby what do you deserve more
gabe success or fried chicken
well i don't deserve fried chicken
that's all i got
oh they're intrinsically tied together
so is your dad i see your dad in the
video sometimes too is that gabe's
brother
no no no my dad is married to my mom
and my mom and gabe are first cousins
okay on the mom's side
got it so okay i think i was very
curious about the family situation with
gabe so i'm glad we got that cleared up
cheers [ __ ] baby [ __ ] with you baby [ __ ]
yeah yeah baby how many white clothes
are we drinking tonight since it's
friday and we're in miami
let's go get [ __ ] up on friday night
yeah hey gabe are you going to be
picking up any girls tonight
friday night in miami i don't know i
don't want to mess with that one
we're going to 11 in miami tonight 11
and miami what's 11.
i think it's absolutely it's like a it's
like a club or something
oh so we don't [ __ ] with the girls
though right gabe no i don't want i
don't want to regret it later in life
oh what a good man responsible
gabe i gotta protect
yeah you know that's a really good take
because it's just a landmine out there
these days and
now that you're famous too it's like you
don't want any girls saying oh
you know we drank a bunch of white claws
and you know what i'm saying
just one thing led to another they don't
want to mess with you and then
it's like a few weeks later oh i'm in
trouble
oh yeah i'll be in trouble for it all of
a sudden
and you and then all of a sudden you got
little white claw gabes running around
you know what i'm saying
yeah i don't want i don't want that
responsibility right now
hell no i'm not with your slow right now
yeah you got too much going on
wow what do you do at the club then
if you're not looking to pick up cuties
just party and drink white clothes just
dancing you know drink a couple um
margaritas or
margaritas gabe's like a music
connoisseur of
all era so anywhere from these to now he
knows like
every genre big hits
yeah so yeah so if you're if you're
playing like a 90s playlist
and we're at like a hangout you can
probably name all the songs without even
having to look at the
yo do you want to give me a trivia
question i want to test games
as a teenager but my parents discouraged
me when i was young
because you know my parents would say
hey you don't have no future in djing
what you gonna do in your life you know
i listen to it and
look what happens you know sometimes i
gotta go where
my aspiration goes you know i should
just listen to myself than my parents
gabe are you um really good at trivia if
we ask you like a music trivia question
yeah it depends i know like most songs
whether there's certain
songs like i know but i don't know the i
don't know the um
the singer but you can try okay here let
me
let me test you okay
who oh this is maybe let's see if you
know this who was awarded the very first
gold record elvis presley
good guess but i don't know who the
answer is it's perry como
oh that's my mom should i try one more
it seems like you're okay let's try one
more let's try one more
sure okay come on now uh i'm waiting for
the question regenerated
white collar gabe ladies and gentlemen
trivia master
music connoisseur [ __ ] yeah baby
[Music]
waiting for the question okay here we go
what singer holds
the most record i'm sorry what singer
holds the world record for most
words and a hit single
that's right what does that even mean
[ __ ]
guys sorry gabe this is not a good
question it's eminem by the way
oh eminem i mean kind of had a feeling
actually yeah
okay this is going sideways sorry
[Laughter]
okay well gabe um
i think you're being modest you're a
ladies man aren't you
um i gotta be i gotta be a gentleman the
girls love him the girls love him that's
what i think
he's a gentleman though yeah okay here
one more time one more time
what was elvis presley's first hit
in 1956
[Music]
is it like hound dog or something good
guess again but it was actually a
heartbreak hotel heartbreak hotel
[Music]
um well
gabe legend thanks for coming by
all right thanks for the opportunity
podcast i don't want to say broadcast
it's podcast
yeah that's right that's right baby yeah
baby [ __ ]
can we just say i want to say [ __ ]
friday dude go out miami have a good ass
time
yeah baby baby do you have school today
is there school today
answer me this gabe is there school
today
[ __ ] no it's quiet it's the weekend is
there work today
there's no work no school it should be a
four day work week a three day weekend
you know
hey are we drinking walk are we drinking
white claws oh yeah
let's celebrate the number on the first
day of the three day weekend baby
let's [ __ ] go [ __ ] baby do you
deserve friday
oh yeah everybody works hard everybody
deserves funny [ __ ] baby yeah
[Applause]
all right keep doing your thing lots of
success and lots of love to you and the
whole family all right take care buddy
all right thanks so much gabe thank you
guys
bye-bye [ __ ] yeah baby
what do you think about white claw hey
it's friday baby [ __ ]
[Applause]
um it's okay yeah it's fine i mean
myself drinking it well it's like i like
drinking i like when i drink i usually
drink like vodka and soda water which is
what this
is yeah it's not too far off from that
it's just vodka and soda water um i
i wonder if i can see some of his oh
yeah here let's see what his cameos are
like
hey i like to give my big wow to the ray
team souls tease baby [ __ ] yeah
yeah baby [ __ ] me saturday night raiding
souls tease baby [ __ ] yeah
b-w-l and kill nerf baby [ __ ] yeah baby
[ __ ] yeah
yeah souls tease baby yeah baby [ __ ]
saturday night baby it's the weekend
baby [ __ ] baby yeah
yeah ready for saturday night baby baby
[ __ ] yeah
it's the weekend the weekend's the life
baby it's saturday night baby [ __ ] baby
why gets five stars he delivers yeah
that's huge you know
you could uh have one of these
um for oh it's 35
oh you can message him for seven dollars
gamie has been wild lately they're
getting all these crazy new options
yeah i don't know what that means just
want to say hi you just
want yeah to just speak with them or
something
you know what that's about here let's
see what this one is hey i want to wish
joe a happy 16th birthday baby [ __ ]
happy birthday yeah you're legal to
drive now baby yeah
happy 16th birthday joe baby yeah good
luck
good luck hopefully you make it through
high school and make it to college
yeah so anyway white club gabe is out on
camera if you guys want to support him
love white club game so nice to get to
meet the man
yeah behind the moon you know
i was always really curious who were all
those people he lived with
i've seen this guy in his videos
apparently he's like yeah apparently
he's an actor i've seen this guy
for sure he's always in the videos um
this dude here
who what's he been in he was in the
longest yard
oh it's a adam sandler movie right oh
for real yep oh
my favorite
you know how i feel about that so that's
gabe
lauren but we have actually a lot of
stuff today planned
um oh i wanted to show this speaking of
jake paul who i will not say a bad thing
about
but so there's this okay
this is like one of these really
ridiculous non-story political
headpieces
so at the olympics they're not allowed
to discuss politics it's supposed to be
like a non-political event
and so they banned flank you know saying
political organizations
and so this company just trying to bait
people goes
um you know the japan the tokyo olympics
has banned black lives matter
that's like yeah they ban all political
organizations so
they make it seem like it's some kind of
headline like oh they're taking a stand
it's like no everybody so anyway uh
look who left a comment greg paul that's
great news
i'm a [ __ ] savage you gotta do it
it's just
i just thought it was so funny but he
felt compelled to come that's great news
but also like you got baited bro because
here's the title japan is playing no
games keeping it 100 i appreciate that
it's like nah bro
they're not making a political statement
everything's banned
so anyway just i was wondering what it
meant i guess
means nothing yeah yeah i'd rather speak
up and be wrong than be muffled
and be wrong
smoking like a true uh philosopher king
yeah yeah baby
that's just that um
let's talk about some other stuff here
we've got
um okay teddy fresh is getting ripped
off again yo
you see this i did and this time so many
people
sent me messages about it so it's from
like dollskill which is a big retailer
i saw they actually made a tweet they
said it's not us it's like this one
other brand
i don't know what the other brand is
but oh here it is yeah so dollskill
here we go death noodles of course on it
as always
uh let's see dollskill has a new
shoe apparently wasn't made by them well
because it's one
it's a website that like sells different
brands you know sure but a lot of i'm
not saying the brands
not a doll skill brand it's a different
brand that they sell
right now i'm not saying they
did this but a lot of times these
companies like dollskill and also urban
outfitter they have these own
like shell clothing brands
that they use to rip off people i don't
know if that's what they're doing i
don't know anything about this shoe
brand but like
urban outfitters all the time where they
have like oh uh
here's a brand that you've never heard
of they make shorts that happen to be
rip-offs from
other people but the what really [ __ ]
shits in my mouth is that they why they
really had to put the teddy bear on
there
like you that's like so aggressive i
agree
like this is a purpose i saw it and i
didn't zoom in and i was like
yeah i mean it's definitely the same
exact colors but then i was like oh wow
and there's a teddy bear why would they
do the teddy bear
this is so whack like the colors are
first of all exact
dips it's not like similar it's an exact
dip it's like they went to the hoodie
and they'd said dip color
paste but the teddy bears it's shameless
yeah it's crazy why would they put the
teddy bear on there it's almost like
they're saying like [ __ ] you
yeah yeah
he's stealing that yeah
but there you go but i mean a compliment
to you you know that these colors are
still
being jacked to this day yeah it's kind
of a
ultimate block in my mind how many
variations of it we've seen by now oh
this girl made a really popular tick
tock it was on my
page shout out to the her family
um this had a lot of views so i was like
cool
yeah we can't stop getting ripped she's
right
dolls kill thank you girl
thanks for defending us yeah appreciate
you
oh speaking of which you know and i
heard that dollskill
allegedly do it a lot yeah a lot of
these big retailers
oh here's her tick tock i don't see how
many people have watched it you know
um speaking of which i know the
colorblock cody's been sold out for a
long time but
um it's coming back this month 2.0 which
is very exciting
so shout out to our family i guess
all right um
trying to pull up all the here it is on
their
instagram page i mean come on dude
really
did good too 30 000 likes
let's see what the comments are you're a
garbage brand ooh oh and another
interesting thing that everyone is
saying is they're deleting all the
comments that i mentioned
oh no come on yeah so
i saw people accusing them that too not
saying that it didn't happen
but when i saw that yesterday i found
some comments mentioning teddy fresh and
screenshotted them to see if they'd be
gone today and they're still there today
it's possible that they just called the
top comments you know yeah it's possible
i mean it was fair the one that i found
was near the top though
interesting yeah anyway um you know
look it's a great design so i'm not
surprised people are jacking it but the
teddy bear head it's so aggressive
you know just toys what the [ __ ]
here it's called koi
uh i think zosie is the brand actually
oh zozie
well i was just going around footwear
koi football is okay footwear yeah yeah
[Music]
have you visited black
what is it what the hell i didn't say
that
you did say it at one point in time
anyway
what can you do huh say love you so is
life
come on
okay here's the next story
dan this is your find you might like
this isn't one of these weird tick tock
accounts that we like to get into
on fridays so according to this guy his
name is grand
rising app um
well his name is william knight i
believe oh
yes but uh grand rising app is his app
that
uh he is promoting with these videos so
you can download that off the app store
can you really yeah it's on well what
are you doing
on an iphone yeah uh i checked it out i
don't have an iphone so i couldn't
download it but i looked into it and it
just
you open it and it just gives you uh a
piece of advice
oh basically like seemingly at random
the grand rising
yeah so similar advice to what he uh
is instructing you in these videos okay
so open your mind are you ready get your
third eye open yeah that's what you need
to do
yeah open your third eye this is yeah by
the way this is gonna wake up 150 000
likes so people are very receptive to
the grand rising
but here there's no such thing as a
coincidence
the fact that you're watching this video
why is his face so unsettling does he
have contacts in or something
i think he's got contacts i mean or
something maybe
his context because his eye there's
something about his face that looks
super unnatural i think it's his
contacts we're energetically aligned
with me
and aquafarians but you mean bro i'm
just scrolling dick dog bro i'm not
that's like saying i'm energetically
aligned with like the [ __ ]
uh you know
the did like the incest couple on the
like scroll on
there's like an incest couple you
remember we watched i'm trying to think
of something funny here
i do remember that yeah that was
disturbing
come on i'm just on tick tock bro it's
not a coincidence it's not a coincidence
i've watched a thousand videos today on
tick tock
it's it's literally just impossible not
to know the math
mermaids mermaid the truth is the being
with the humanoid torso
and fish there's only one type of in
fact
there are many more advanced aquatic
beings okay this is what i lost
what there's like a big ass
titty fish apparently in the ocean
swimming around
looks very um water dynamic looks like
it would glide
effortlessly titties yeah i have no idea
what he's doing i love that he's talking
about
advanced species and then it cuts to
this
yeah that's the pinnacle of evolution
that's right
remember only five people what does it
mean what does the ocean animal need
with big ass
[ __ ] titties like they're they
feeding milk in the ocean
uncharted one of the elite's biggest
secrets kept from earth humans
are the amounts of cities they have
discovered underwater shut up
they want you to believe every
underwater city is the result of a flood
or natural disaster
but the truth is a lot of these cities
are the remains of ancient
underwater civilizations purposely built
underwater
by aquafarians either that's for one big
question
based on this fishy with titties that's
obviously fake
so let's just take a mermaid it is he's
got a bunch
of these so open your third eye this
one's about aliens trying to wake up my
third eye wake up
joel biden there's no such thing as a
coincidence
the fact that you're watching this video
means you are energetically aligned
with me and what i'm about to show you
with all this talk it's like bro i just
watched a thousand videos
i just watched bryce hall like dance fan
you know try to look sexy there's
there's no coincidence the pentagon
confirming ufos
and countless videos of light from the
sky
you're probably wondering where's the
real extraterrestrial approach
music copyrighted let me know i i
re-uploaded
so i looked into this this actually is
real oh
this was like a skeleton that they found
and but
what he's saying right now they tested
his dna and he's gonna say that it's
like not
human dna that that's just not true it
is a human it was like
you know a horribly uh deformed baby or
something
yeah um that's sad why are you gonna use
this poor
child to like talk about it from like a
thousand years ago
making the idea of aydah being an unborn
fetus impossible
peter has 10 ribs instead of the human
amount 12 an elongated skull
and large i don't want to look at this
even with the never before seen
even have some shame bro
here let's learn about bigfoot
the fact that you're watching this is no
coincidence
i just farted in my hand and smelled it
there's no such thing as a coincidence
there's literally no such thing as a
coincidence
if there's no hi my you're on my page
and that's no coincidence
i just buttercup to my own face think
about that
hi you've hit my page there's no such
thing as a coincidence
there's no such thing as a coincidence
so somebody explained why i just blasted
my
diarrhea from eating way too much salsa
the night before
now we're energetically aligned there's
no such thing as a coincidence
look how off the screen you are oh sorry
there's coins there's no such thing as a
coincidence
that's why i was cheese grating parmesan
cheese and shredded my nail off my thumb
the other night
there's no such thing as a coincidence
that was not a coincidence that you
energetically aligned with him just oh
my god
there is no such thing as a coincidence
that's why
that's why uh theodore puked down my
shirt a few nights ago
there's no such thing as a coincidence
[Music]
we are energetically aligned right now
i just made parm i just made them uh i
just made a steak and
burned it i cooked it for too long no
such thing there's no such thing as the
coincidence
we are energy we are energetically
aligned right now
[Music]
one time such thing as a coincidence one
time when i was a boy
i got in a fight with somebody over
craft over these little lunchable things
with the red stick
do you spread cheese on oh yeah there's
we are energetically lying
as a coincidence
we are energetically aligned right now
there's no such thing as a coincidence
one time when i was like
five we were pl i was playing with toys
with my best friend
and we threw them in a hole and both
started peeing on it for some reason
and his mom came out and said there's no
such thing as the coincidence
there's uh go ahead zach there's there's
no such thing as a coincidence
we are energetically aligned right now
wait you're way too far away from the
camera oh here here's here's a sit up a
little bit
there perfect i got a close-up on you
yesterday i was walking around
disneyland and i saw
just randomly gus johnson there is no
such thing as a coincidence
there's no such thing as we are
energetically aligned right now
there's no such thing as a coincidence
um i'm trying to think of something else
good
i wish i had fun maybe let's watch more
yeah
yeah let's watch the bigfoot one a group
of scientific professionals spent five
years and five hundred thousand dollars
to find the being you know as bigfoot
with an overwhelming number of photos
videos and dna samples it's not
overwhelming there's like nothing
overwhelming
overwhelming what do i do with all these
bigfoot photos
and dna i am overwhelmed
there's literally one photo that
everybody uses that was
taken like 40 years ago we are
energetically aligned right now
you are overwhelmed by bigfoot photos in
dna
we finally know the truth about this
creature before dinner starts i'd like
to point out
that just about everybody at this table
has seen them
is this the overwhelming evidence yeah
the furry people do exist
rip jc johnson there is no such thing as
a coincidence
the fact that you're on my page right
now means bigfoot is real
there is no coincidence that we are
aligned
some cases right alongside of us some
cases right outside of i've seen a dude
i knew named
bailey he was real hairy boy and tall
too no such things as a coincidence here
high urban areas residential
neighborhoods some of them take up
occupations
in old abandoned buildings you would be
surprised
oh jc johnson died he ripped jc johnson
a rose on his grave
a you just be surprised how
human-like these bigfoot are in fact
many many people just mistaken for
humans
he literally said that
[Laughter]
the different ways can some people just
think they're humans
boy i know better than that though um
they ain't no coincidence in this world
a group this is probably his worst video
i can't get over the overwhelming
evidence and it's just a guy being like
someone i've seen bigfoot man they look
real life like
a human like i tell you what most people
just think they're humans
i know the dirt foot though
there's no such thing as a coincidence
the fact that you're watching this video
right now
means that there are extraterrestrials
on this earth the size of
my pinky that silently cr that crawl my
butthole at night and clean my anus
there are no such things as a
coincidence i haven't pooped in a week
there's evidence that aliens have been
harvesting the poop out of my butt
the fact that you're watching this video
right now is means that there's no such
thing as a question there's no such
thing as
we are energetically aligned the earth
is hollow there's that is the energy we
are energetically aligned
[Music]
did you know the earth is flat we are
energetically aligned
there's overwhelming evidence that the
earth is flat
there's no such thing as a coincidence
cut to the scientist i've seen
it man i've been up there in a hot
balloon man and the earth doesn't even
seem curved at all man
some people think that it is flat but i
know better there is no such thing as
coincidence the evidence is overwhelming
that the earth is flat
rest in peace to uh tom willett wake up
bigfoots are real i s i seen them man
they look like just like my cousin jim
about the same height and about the
right furnace but i'll tell you what man
those bigfoots are real
so most people think they're human but
i'll tell you man i know the truth
overwhelming evidence says bigfoot is
real no such thing as a coincidence
there's no such thing as a coincidence
here's one on witches
this is the best [ __ ] tick tock i'm
so glad you found this damn
you gotta try to win the zoom to like
step in yeah right oh okay sure i'll try
that out the next one
here i want to learn about witches
though have you ever
wondered why which is where all no
you're like nope
never wondered that okay and i'll bite
black absorbs light oh [ __ ] the more
light energy you have
the more powerful you are every cell in
our body
acts as a solar panel to light energy
say what next time you're in the sun
take off your hats what does that have
to do with them wearing glasses
in charge bro i tried charging up and
[ __ ]
they had to get part of my skin cut off
because i had cancer
he's this started with why do witches
wear black and then he went off about
how
your cells absorb something they wear
black
he goes take off your hat take off your
glasses
don't wear sunscreen i was like damn
dude
not good advice
decalcify your pineal gland say what
your pineal gland is where your human
abilities
lie dormant the same pineal gland
tells birds to fly soft for the winter
it tells bears when to hibernate
when to wake up and it also is the
reason why you can see so
vividly while you're dreaming it's a
massive penis charge up
and share this lesson with a friend any
questions
yeah have you ever watched a lot of
questions there is no coincidence on
this planet
go out in the sun don't wear sunscreen
see what happens
if you get suns if you get cancer and
die
you are just a human piece of [ __ ] if
you survive and get human powers
you're a witch we are connected and
there are no
coincidences in this world
why wait wait step in or like fly in
there are no quenches around the world
why do i keep losing socks
there's clearly an explanation there are
aliens that mine
socks for me why do i only have one sock
of so many pairs the fact you're on this
page
proves my point because there are no
coincidences there's no such thing as
the coin
okay here i come
medusa is real one time i saw my nana
showering
and i got froze up and i couldn't move
it was so shocking
there are no coincidences explain that
why is it when i saw my nana showering
naked i froze up
the fact that you're on this page right
now means it's true
there's no such thing as a coincidence
can you talk about the gland the new
human abilities
that you didn't what did you call it he
just called it human abilities
the pineal gland pineal gland
the penis gland the fact that you're
watching this video right now
proves that we're energetically aligned
did you know that the pineal gland
can also make your penis uh super
super hard to get up that's why you
gotta go sit in the sun
and get skin cancer there are no coins
there's no such thing as a coincidence
yo i'm digging this white claw ouch
you want another one i'm still working
i'm not trying to actually
i don't know i'm afraid to actually get
toasted on the
live yeah good good point i just hurt my
knee
oh [ __ ] he's got a pretty you okay oh
there's like jagged
bits on the bottom he must have hit
something
he's got he's looking pretty fly in this
one about uh wit uh
the matrix is a true movie
hollywood and witchcraft go hand in hand
the name hollywood
derives from the holly tree harry
potter's wand
made out of hollywood hollywood media
wait harry potter's in on this
conspiracy
oh my god some english writer
is in on the hollywood conspiracy
showing you one of three things what the
elite have done too in the past
what the elite is currently doing to you
or what the elite plan on doing to you
in the future
here are three movies that disguise the
truth as fiction
they live a 1988 movie that follows a
guy who wakes up to the truth
about subliminal messaging and a secret
community
of extraterrestrials hiding in plain
sight
fahrenheit 451 a classic novel made into
a film
about a future society full of
surveillance and censorship
where books are burned and knowledge is
illegal the matrix
one of the greatest documentaries ever
made
follow for part two and share this video
sorry i just remembered that i need to
order this medicine for today
okay do it now anyway i've had my phone
and then the mate just remember the
matrix is the best document i ever made
are you scared or wait was it are you
scared not enough that was lord of the
rings
well which is it the red pill or the
blue pill
this is not a joke this is a documentary
about your life
wake up i noticed his all work connected
to energetically
kind of a new development on his channel
yeah i seems to have coincided with his
app launch
so smart oh you know what i want to do
for sure
is do the um you guys saw that prince
william and kate middleton
made a youtube channel um right yeah
exciting news you know we care
we have deep reverence for the royalty
here on this channel yes and family
blogs
family exactly our two most are
important things in our in our community
uh royalty and family vlogs and um
their video was number one trending
super hot super hip
you could tell these royalty are
different than what you expect they're
connected with the young people and
they're ready to change
you know yeah they're a lot like us here
because these guys they're filming i
know by the way you'll be careful what
you're saying now because these guys
they're filming
hey
let the conversation yo
i can't get over how
uninteresting the royalty is like it's
so
[ __ ] antiquated i'm just sorry i'm
not looking at this guy
and being like i need to like worship
this is so cool
i mean he looks he's just like bro i
just don't care
he's better than us what are you talking
i just don't get that vibe and trust me
i do think some people are better you
know he
he's not him though he's a lot better
than us
i like that i really like that i like
that
so anyway now that they're coming to
youtube
um we thought we actually got
um some pre they haven't launched
anything other than the trailer
but we actually were able to get a hold
of a preview of some of their content
really it was leaked online yeah and um
i'll actually want to show you guys i'm
pretty hyped based off of what i've seen
well they want to be youtubers so here
we found some of their thumbnails leaked
online
who is she who is this girl by the way
that she's admiring do we know
i don't ian you're british
i think it's the queen of hearts uh the
queen of cars
wow um here's another one five thousand
pound beans on toast
they're doing a taste test of beans on
toast very popular in england
and of course they would be eating
expensive and it's a great video format
can't wait to see that one yeah i would
watch that i mean just they're right on
point here
um the queen is doing a yard sale
oh oh no what
it looks like she's selling her royal
jewels on at the yard sale
wow this is some good i'm looking
forward to watching this
oh five billion orbeez
in windsor castle they filled the whole
damn castle with orbeez
oh mr beast watch out the royals are
coming
[Music]
i'm sorry oh no
making an apology man what did she do i
wonder
she's on the kitchen floor well yeah she
learned from the best yeah
that's gonna be an authentic apology man
i wonder what she did
for real oh no
oh contacting prince philip
a little soon for that that seems like a
low block oh
man prince sorry who's charles and who's
philip again
phillip is uh is uh he's the reason he's
the one that just
dearly departed who we lost so here's
too soon
his own son charles is doing a ouija
board 3 a.m challenge with his dad who
recently passed away
that is so inappropriate for doing that
but he needs to click
you know what i'm saying he's got to
grow his channel somehow that's dirty
um uncle andrew did once oh
oh no that that that is a family drama
oh that you know ankle andrew of course
was a no was uh friends with
the recently departed uh epstein another
one who left us too soon
and just outraged within the royal
family lots of gossip
oh is that all of them yeah that's all
we were able to obtain
so far but i hear they're cooking up a
lot of good content so
i'm really you know oh and he's all wet
i remember because the girl said he was
real sweaty right
so he's sweating so
like yeah there's a lot of it sounds
like they're right on track to be huge
youtubers
you gotta subscribe yeah
so stay tuned uh their youtube channel
again is
what is their youtube channel um
yeah let's see i think they just have
this video
just like they got a banner look at that
yeah oh they put up a new video
is it one of the ones that we just
previewed wait what the [ __ ] is this
shielding myla
yo what is this okay let's see
[Music]
yo i thought you guys were supposed to
be eating beans and [ __ ] like who wants
to watch this he's in the photographs as
well doesn't he mean that
okay this content sucks i mean yeah kind
of
with peace and love they're already
missing the point
all right i'm out garbage
so it's pretty exciting how long we've
been going because i got a few more
stories here i'm wondering
uh we've been going for two hours 22
minutes and 55 seconds
how many seconds now 57 now 58 59 this
is the thing
this story is pretty bad together a lot
of people have been talking about this
next story
which is the youtubers nikki and dan
felipe
who put their dog down after a bit their
son
i don't know if you guys heard about
this but
i'll briefly explain
they put out a video so this is a dog i
guess these guys been vlogging for a
while
and they've had this dog bowser in their
life for like 10 years this is their
family dog right
and they put out this video saying that
they
uh put their dog down because he bit
their son
but the way the delivery of the video is
just so
[ __ ] off bro
um i'm really curious by the way
i questioned the details of this video
because it this is their family dog
that's been with them 10 years i just
can't imagine not being able to find a
resolution there
i don't get it and just as i haven't
watched it yet and i haven't
i've obviously heard about it i saw
people talk about it but i haven't
watched the video yet
but i just can't imagine like why is
that the only option
i mean i i would i would never put my
dog down for anything less than
terminal illness and they were just like
uh suffering that there's nothing that
would ever make me kill my dog
but the way he talks about it here you
got to see this the [ __ ] they say is
beyond
insane on friday we
had to put bowser to sleep um
and i don't know why they can't they
came out and made this whole video like
trying to get sympathy and
you know dan is with me because
bowser was i mean he was our dog
but he was dan's dog um and
this was not a decision we came to
lightly
you know when dan and i were first
talking about this and
just how this was all going to unfold
and just having conversations around it
one of the things that we said or i said
was i was like people aren't
people aren't going to get it like
people are going to be upset
and dan's response was that was a bird
dan's response was nobody's going to be
as upset
as i'm upset or as upset as i am um
and so that's wrong about that yeah
that's the position that we're we're in
today
so i feel like i don't know do you want
to say hi i feel like i'm just like
talking yeah
well i mean we've had
bowser for over almost a decade and
uh yo i don't see i don't see it uh the
part where he compares him to old yeller
i don't see that in the time stamps am i
missing it it's in there i highlighted
it
oh here this part really [ __ ] rubbed
me so wrong
here watch this space you know
yeah things just became more complicated
than this mid this mid phase of like
he's not a baby baby
but he's not old enough to know better
how to control himself
really and so that just made bowser
really unpredictable and thinking that
like
god willing we have more children well
then it's going to start all over again
and then who knows what kind of chaos is
going to be there with two kids combined
with the fact that bowser is older
combined with the fact that he already
got physical on logan combined with the
fact that
he's done these are all just waters it
was so much it's not like we
scheduled him to get put down the day we
got back from vacation
no no we hadn't even thought about it
still when we left we were just like
bowser's got to get out of here he's got
to be re-homed like this is not the
appropriate home for him
and like i said it was that conversation
with that woman that was
like you guys you can't well we were out
the door
right and in the moment i'm thinking the
coffee drink they're so not
upset watch she puts her head on his
shoulder
was it a
[Music]
he's fine i mean it doesn't seem like he
was seriously injured
from what i can tell right i mean you
guys looked into this
the kid was fine oh they said he wasn't
that injured yeah
but i see some people in the chat it was
it was because the kid tried to take the
dog's food
yeah yeah i mean we have to
hit his face we have to manage this kind
of situations
all the time with theodore and the dogs
but it's like if you're
i've i feel like as the owner you can
figure it out
i'm not like sometimes two will like
pull them or something yeah they'll kind
of like snap
but i don't know it's all manageable
i can't imagine really like well yeah
and like
the thing is they try to make their dog
sound like some like
crazy uncontrollable yeah it's like he's
been in the family for 10 years since he
was like a very young dog that makes no
sense this is his home and his parents
there's just it doesn't make any sense
to me
uh i just feel like especially because
we have dogs and we have a kid
i see those situations it's really not
like
that like you can manage it but also
well here listen to this part today
we got back from vacation no no
actually we hadn't even thought about
this where is it you know
yeah things just just let it play it'll
do this mid
phase of like he's not a baby baby okay
you went way too far back
over again and then who knows what kind
of chaos is going to be there with two
kids
combined with the fact that deposit you
went too far back
let me just find it maybe it's not
[Music]
and in the moment i'm thinking
you know i grew up with the movie old
yeller and i wanted to pick
bowser up by the back of the neck and
take him into the backyard and put him
down right there
so this absolute psycho says because he
grew up with old yeller
a movie by the way of this family has
this beloved
dog the dog i think he gets rabies from
an animal def
by defending the family right yeah he
gets rabies he gets rabies which is
which is when the dog gets rabies they
become dangerous and it's fatal
they're going to die and they become
like unpredictable
and so this guy says old yeller
who had to be put down by the owner that
loved him most in the world because he
had an incurable disease
he's comparing that to a dog that nipped
his son
his son was unharmed and he wanted to
immediately take him in the backyard
and murder the dog in front of his son
by the way who's at the house at the
same time
this guy is so unhinged this is so
disgusting
i literally cannot believe they even put
this out like what are you doing yeah
the he i don't know he thinks this is
like macho or something to take his dog
in the backyard and murder it yeah it
does seem like he thinks he's
mr he's being alpha yeah mr alfonso i
mean psycho bro
is spinning psycho alpha maybe
maybe fine yeah but listen this [ __ ]
lunatic
i actually didn't end up leaving that
day we ended up going to the airport
and then there was just a few things
that happened
why are you laughing cancelled it and
schedule it for the next day so
we got home and we ended up having
like the best day like all day they look
like
two people that are trying to look like
they feel bad
oh for sure it's like i don't know
by the way he goes we went on vacation i
had the best day ever
and after i had like gone and had the
best day ever i still came back and
wanted to kill my dog
but we didn't travel today and have the
worst day
you know we came back and we all had the
best day
together so ah
so weird is this this is just so weird
yeah so like you said um how's she gonna
go
she went from shoulder to yeah so
after you know these people are so glad
their dog is dead like i'm sorry
and then the thing is like they're so
glad their dog is dead and then they're
coming out here just to make like a vid
just to make content on it and try to be
like oh just why did this need to be a
video
like if this happened like can exactly
like why is this a video because they
needed content
they needed content yeah i guess you
know and there's here i'll show i'm
going to keep showing more about these
guys
because we kind of dug into it a little
bit but like they didn't need to kill
their dog there's people that would have
taken that there's so many people that
are against kill shelters i don't know
where they're located but i know here in
l.a pretty much anyone will take your
[ __ ] dog rather than you kill it i
had a really great day with him you know
he was fed really good food
taking on a really beautiful outdoor
drive the weather unlike today
was perfect it was so beautiful
we played with bowser in the back so you
killed your dog bro who cares about this
relaxed with him and um like i mentioned
we did it at our house so we paid for
boys people are like coffee that day was
so
perfect starbucks nailed it i got the
way at the facility and we were just
like we can't oh he also mentioned
uh that he wanted to kill his dog a few
years earlier too didn't he
um he's been thinking about killing his
dog for a while
[Music]
the fact that they had this dog for 10
years just make no sense that
this couldn't have been resolved i would
rather i
mean we adopted alfredo while we had
and pretty much a newborn baby in the
house and alfredo had some anger
problems in the beginning it we managed
it it was fine well i think they're i
mean
i mean it's like look it can be
challenging for moments but you get over
it
you have responsibility to that animal
that yes
they're not little [ __ ] toys for you
to murder when you're done but if you're
there and you're a responsible owner
it's not some kind of like i don't know
you can figure it out
i think they're bad i think they're bad
doggy parents because
that's why the dog's acting up that's
what i'm saying yeah
you know if the dog felt safe and loved
you wouldn't it wouldn't be an issue
um there's a few other great ones
crazy oh here you go this is this one
ian can you describe where they talked
about killing their dog before
um
i think he might be looking for that
other thing oh he's gone yeah
where did he go got disconnected maybe
no
i'm trying to find
it's coming back oh here they say it
listen to this
like imagine saying this in the video
where you killed your dog because he
nipped your son
so all that being said i
mean bowser
has he was the best animal ever owned
really why'd you kill him
dude you are such a freak yeah now i
now i think that bull terrier is my
favorite animal period
oh oh his wife is such a phony
so i want to say one more thing actually
before we go where's my phone
i wrote a list dude they're so happy
they killed the dog
holding a [ __ ] yorkie or coffee
she's like oh i'm so sorry
hopefully i don't have to throttle this
yorkie if it nips me ian where's the
part where she said
they thought about killing their dog for
a while
uh give me a second here let me look
she's like i wrote a script i mean a
list
of uh all the things i loved about
bowser
he's the one thing i like about bowser
he's dead
[Music]
we don't have to buy dog food anymore
um poop anymore people say they had a
photo shoot what is that about
you guys know something about the photo
shoot they well here it's in the it's in
the
doctor there's too much [ __ ] here with
peace and love you got to help your
stuff like there's like
tons of there's just way too much stuff
here oh here's the photo shoot thank you
um yeah because back in the day they
were making a ton of content with this
dog about how much they love him and
stuff
they even said like he used to be their
baby before their kid was born
i'm sorry i do not love my dogs lust and
other theodore's here
i have love in my heart for all of them
of course
you know that's the same logic as being
like oh well now that my new baby's here
i don't love my old days they're just
like a kid i mean
and then and theodore loves them and so
it's a whole yeah
so they're part of the family look at
this you
freak bro you betrayed that dog that
loved you and you killed him
there i cannot express how disgusted i
am
i would die before i put my dogs down
for any reason other than absolute
terminal illness
you hear that alfredo and shredder
shadow's like i know [ __ ] i own you
shred is
this comment says they did a photo shoot
after the kid was bit
with the dog before they killed him eh
is that true
he's like i was gonna take him in the
backyard and put him down like old
dealer
but instead we did a photo shoot before
i took up to the vet
yeah i mean i think that's the photos
we're looking at really yeah the yeah
this was titled they
they did a photo shoot with bowser dude
you are that you could spend your dog is
healthy
and happy there is right next to the kid
yeah what do you mean
happy and healthy and look how happy and
unscared the kid is the kid is not
scared yes
what do you mean if you could do a photo
shoot together you could do everything
else
i am so disturbed oh my god i'm so
disturbed by this story
i don't know anything about these people
but you know if we we started digging
through some of their old stuff like
look at this for example
here's one of their old videos where
they're antagonizing this dog right
with their new yorkie so they keep
shoving the yorkie in his face
actually he's trying to play but the
yorkie's getting all aggressive on him
what kind of game is this it's a [ __ ]
game for sick weirdos
whose phone is this did you all see that
it's like some weird
it's the wrestling it's the weird
baptism dawn yeah yo what kind of videos
on this one
yeah i think it's a spilling tea that's
just
screaming but why the [ __ ] that their
next video
um the girl the woman by the way like to
tweet saying bad dogs come from
libertared owners
what yep here uh when like a while ago
apparently they're like total uh i'm
looking at their channels such like
love energy nikki felipe who was facing
blasphem
backlash for putting her dog down
allegedly liked a tweet that said bag
dogs have libtard owners
her husband dan allegedly responded to
fans saying does your husband know you
are using the internet
but
i didn't understand that one but okay
peace and love
also apparently the woman is an
anti-vaxxer unrelated
knew it literally just looking at the
grid of their videos
and their thumbnails like that um
not surprising nikki in this clip which
i won't show
because it has that garbage in it um
is a total psycho apparently she's
promoting this guy
a big tree who has no medical training
he's one of the most prominent
anti-vaxxers please
has been criticized by the
anti-defamation league the auschwitz
birkin memorial museum how do you get
[ __ ] on by auschwitz museum
oh because this guy she likes and
follows he wears a star of david at
anti-vaccination events
to compare his treatment to those who
were persecuted during world war
ii i just sorted their videos
by most popular their top thing says
something about hillsong isn't that like
the weird
creepy church that uh bieber goes to and
stuff
i don't know anything about that is that
right ian this is her husband's um
avatar for his channel nice you like
that
here's the earliest video i could find
with them the fact that i understand you
know i still didn't get over the fact
that they did a photo shoot with the dog
i'm still kind of stuck on that like
that's just that right there tells us
it's all for social everything was fine
yeah you guys were fine yeah if you were
able to do a photo shoot with the kid
and the dog together
here here's what we're talking about
here's an idea if your dog has food
anxiety
by the way which after 10 years if your
dog has food anxiety okay
you're [ __ ] weird but maybe just feed
him somewhere else where your son can't
get to him
put him in the [ __ ] closet feed him
in the backyard
they're like no we gotta kill him like
old yeller i grew up watching old yeller
boy
and that just made me want to kill my
dog someday yeehaw
here they are eight years ago doing a
photo shoot with their little puppy
they're like one day i'm gonna kill that
dog like old yeller woo
i grew up watching that film boy yeah
also if you have a following it should
be so easy to be able to find him a new
home
oh yeah like you have such a big rage i
like my dogs like i like my vaccinations
non-existent yeehaw
[Applause]
they had 1.2 million subs but
prior to this video which obviously got
a lot of attention
uh it seemed like their channel was
pretty dead they're only getting 20
000 views on most of their videos yeah i
knew i knew that
well trisha told me they used to be big
and i don't know they fell off
i don't know anything about them but i
do know one thing
i like my dogs like i like my
non-vaccinated grandparents
dead i don't remember that accent
in that video they're from tennessee
right there's no eggs
come on you know they're white trash you
don't know
anything about wine come on now what
i got a down old yeller here i think my
dog got rabies
oh let's just pretend
my dog had rabies had to put him down
boy
excuse me there was no accent
i'm gonna get back on track i had this
dog for 10 years but he was my kid
look at borean this dog was my son
before i had a son
but now i do have a son imma kill him
i'll be cooking up my dog tonight i had
to kill him because he nipped my son
yeah
we're coming to barbecue tonight we're
eating dog
[Music]
only come over if you have not maybe i
mean people are
this is the worst bit that we do on the
show hands down i just i gotta put it
out there
i gotta put it like i mean
i mean about the godfather thing but
like i just play that up
because it's funny to be like oh no
don't do it and then you do it and it's
funny we're having a barbecue with our
dog
you can only come over if you're not
vaccinated yeehaw
let's go now i'm trying to spread you
don't know the character and that's
it's not all like that this is a very
limited character you got here
there's a lot of like anti-vaxxers that
are not
white trash educated hippie type of
taunt in california yes a lot here right
here
in l.a huge amount of anti-vaccines my
preacher
said it's okay
he said my preacher said when the
barbecue i'm coming over eat that dog
zach throw off the videos people saying
i just saw some uh
chad saying zack's an enabler
[Laughter]
come on here dan now boy
[Music]
we come on down to my house now we got
no dogs and no that makes no sense
stop the fire boy we got no dogs
we got we got no dogs and no
vaccinations
all right ethan come on now
jesus is your source i hate welfare okay
did you get those food seriously
yeah then like the california kind
though
i'm not talking about them i'm talking
about these people that murder their
dogs nikki and dan
she doesn't she looks more like one of
those that you would see here
exactly that's why it's more like he's
the live laugh love what do you guys got
to
over analyze crystal healing energy
why y'all gotta over analyze my [ __ ]
it's a little bigoted
okay
look at you you you elite living in los
angeles
all right you're the most it's hard to
hear stop
trying to act better than me you're like
mr [ __ ] libtard
stop i take issue with you calling me a
liberal of course you don't but you are
yeehaw my name is dance we're looking at
it i'm over here i
i go up to the strangers on the street
and i poke them with vaccines
yeehaw chill the [ __ ] out you sensitive
little [ __ ] libtard
well she liked to tweet calling someone
a libtard so she's like you gotta be
white trash
can i get some yeehaws in the chat hey
man i'll let you do this character
after you travel to me no don't bring
the music
can i get some yeehaws in the chat can i
if you ain't been vaccinated
you type yeehaw in the chat now yeah
if you ain't killed a dog if you killed
your dog who was not terminally ill can
i get a yeehaw in the chat i want you
know what does love think
[Applause]
he's thinking stupid he's singing god
damn man america
hey love you ain't ever been have you
been vaccinated
love i don't know get me a yeehaw now
give me a yeehaw fascination
there's no such thing as a coincidence
i'll tell you what when i be handing out
little bits of my dog during this barbie
i'll be also handing out fresh covet
yeehaw herd immunity will only be
achieved once we all catch cover that's
what president said we
my nana been living long enough boy i'm
getting tired of paying her nursing bill
huh
i got oh i'm seeing yee haws in the chat
now boy
[Applause]
get me down by the rodeo now abe do you
happen to have any white
trash kind of family or friends yes my
mom's
what do you think about that what do you
think about this
he just called his family white trash
white trash is it's not necessarily what
you think it is
don't you see you're already ruined your
argument by saying no
ab what do you think can i get a yeehaw
please
i think uh i'm right on let it stop
i don't i don't know i don't see a
problem to be honest
you don't see them talk like this now do
they talk like that
uh well they call yeah sometimes they're
like oh
why where the hell where are they from
what
the [ __ ] are you talking about they talk
like that i'm telling you my mom's
where are they from you've you got
colonel sanders listen hold up hold up
my my mom's cousins anytime's like oh
dale is here come on dale come on over
here come on over here now dad
yeah bring it and leave that vaccinating
card at home boy we don't look at that
now
oh i heard you put your dog down bring
them already out here for the bobby
we desperate for meat boy frogs dogs
of course oh we got something gator now
we can put some gator on the bobby
gator on the boat oh yeah burn some
trash
come on down to the trailer we're going
to burn some trash
everyone everyone in tennessee to
ethan's just bobby boucher
from waterboy that's the thing it kind
of
kind of it kind of floats through like
louisiana
or and then it's like antebellum like
he said why not starve not
and that's why i kill my dog for food
amen speared to death i would take
i would take like an eight-part hbo
mini-series
of just the godfather impression
over five minutes of this
oh no
you will come to me on my show
you will come to me on my show your head
on the mic on this beautiful friday it's
friday
[ __ ] yeah baby is this a collab
i deserve to do a white dress impression
it's a mash-up
and all of you come here tell me stop
stop what am i gonna do with this dog
i killed it in the backyard like old
yellow
and now what am i going to bury it oh my
god eat with all my clothes
maybe the show's gone for too long
my doctor says i should be vaccinated i
say
[Music]
[Music]
can i just say the chat guessed exactly
where my mom's family's from in michigan
based on the accent yeehaw come on how
about that michigan burn some trash
down river baby that's right come on
baby i just broke into the hospital and
dumped all the vaccine down now that's
what jesus would do
jesus said break into the hospital and
burn that vaccine boy yeehaw
and we're done we're gonna go down down
to the abortion clinic and uh and
thinking and
officially quit we gonna go harass some
women getting abortions at the lowest
point in their day yeehaw that's what we
do down here
let's go congregate without vaccines
oh yeah
oh boy we hate them libtards getting
vaccinated for us
them libtards get vaccinated so that we
don't get covered
there's not even an accent anymore
it's just slowly bled away i can't
believe you hate it so much
i hate it oh look you stopped any on his
back
well zack stopped the music he betrayed
me
you guys are so dramatic just having fun
trying to entertain people
you come in here on friday when i'm
trying to have a good time and doing my
impressions
you break my heart dan you break my
heart
i brought you in
[Music]
i brought you into the family what do
you think about this
for four years we work together and you
sit here
you break mine i know it was you freedom
how could you do this to your
your grandfather your papa i might be
the grandfather but i've never sick
myself with a vaccine
needle this is all the farce
the grandfather the godfather i don't
know
you guys want to talk about garyvee
let's change the subject
i just i don't i know a lot of people
like garyvee so you know
okay don't [ __ ] kill me but the guy
said some funny [ __ ]
i saw this tick tock and i just died bro
this was on my for you page i was like
sorry listen to this who do you love the
most in the world
my family once a day genuinely sit there
for five minutes and make pretend one of
them got shot in the face
i was like what i was like no thanks
i'm sorry this dude is a chill a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] who is scaring me
he's like one of these [ __ ] gurus i
don't know
he's like a motivational speaker kind of
guy he's one of these guys that pretends
he's got all the [ __ ] answers and he
just acts super confident and people
believe him guy
uh tony yeah tony robbins he's similar
to tony robbins yeah he uh
i believe he's an entrepreneur tony
robbins got his deep best voice
in gary's defense he's known for being
kind of the opposite of those guys
i know like just wait opposite of
donating
a b is a garyvee fan you should say both
baby and love
are gary vee what do you guys like about
gary vee because he seems to me
like every other [ __ ] motivational uh
i
have all the answers [ __ ]
no it well first of all he's not selling
a course you know he doesn't oh he never
does sell you a course
i mean he has he had no yeah he has his
like youtube channel and he has his
you know he's never tried to make money
he doesn't do like the seminar style
books he doesn't have seminars where's
he right now
oh right i know but i'm just saying it's
not he's not like uh
no shame type of guy i feel like i don't
know a lot of the stuff he said has got
me a lot of jobs to be honest
like he okay he puts well do you sit at
home for five minutes and imagine lena
being shot in the face
because it's supposed to make you happy
uh not being shot in the face but
anytime like i'm sad about something or
stressed out i
you know i'm just i try to be thankful
because like that'd be my that's already
he said sit at home right genuinely
yeah genuinely he literally emphasizes
genuinely
right once a day genuinely sit there for
five minutes and make pretend one of
them got shot in the face
i probably once a week to four times a
week sit there truly in the shower
try to convince myself that i have lost
one of the five
do you understand what he's he's
fantasizing every day in the shower
that someone close to him has been
murdered the dissolve to the stock
footage yeah the water
photo in the shower baby defend this
clip
most important people in my life and
that is the biggest thing i do
that leads to the biggest happiness i
have nothing makes me happier than
imagining my family being murdered
violently yeah i think about it all the
time i think about it
every day just being beaten to a bloody
pulp it makes me so
happy that is the biggest happiness i
have
like once a day what genuinely sell
enough earrings today
people lack perspective it's actually
remarkably easy
if it becomes the way you see the world
okay shut up it's a little too
aggressive for me
i don't know to me i mean okay good he
helps people what am i i'm just an
[ __ ] yeah no problem
i i've found in because i i wasn't
really that familiar with him but
when we pulled together all these clips
i found that uh
you know the underlying message of a lot
of what he's saying
like be thankful for the things you have
don't sweat the small stuff i mean yeah
of course it's all
kind of general advice it's his like
method of delivery is always so
aggressive
like we we have some more we'll see like
he shocks
yeah he's just so angry at home and
imagine someone you love
was and actually do this i'm not
exaggerating actually
this shot in the [ __ ] face here
here's another one i don't know what i'm
watching so let's see
three words just give me inspiration for
any damn falling down
three words three words you're gonna die
yeah that's inspiration about it do
something about it
i love you i love you too take care i
don't know
i don't like these large these guys who
paint themselves as these larger than
life guys because it's [ __ ]
this guy can sit here like he has the
answers he's rehashing the same dumb
[ __ ] that everybody [ __ ] says
and yeah okay sure he helps people but
like it's so grandiose it's self-self
congratulatory i just
we're all just stumbling through life
and i don't think that this type of vice
can actually ev i feel personally the
only time you actually ever learn is
from doing things yourself
you can sit and watch some [ __ ] talk
all [ __ ] day but i feel like
it's all just temporary relief that's my
[ __ ] guru moment
i'm larger than life damn your thoughts
baby you're a robot
well i just i just think you know not
everyone has someone in their life that
could help
give them a path you know and of course
there's
different sides you know but some people
need someone like him or a teacher or
someone that kind of gives them
direction
you know they look up to them and even
if someone on the other side isn't 100
sincere it does help them
guide them as to what direction mentors
who said that
i don't know mentors the one thing i've
learned in my life
yeah so he's you found your mentor
okay not me personally but oh here he is
dropping an f-bomb at
elementary school this guy is so
desperate to get a reaction from his
audience
he'll literally say an f-bomb at
elementary school just to make
people in this room when they get on in
the future and they're posted this by
the way bragging that he's
talking to elementary school assembly so
like five-year-olds running a hundred
million dollar business
they're gonna be like i'm not [ __ ]
with he was mean to me
but on the flip side if they're like i
always like
who the [ __ ] would bring this guy to
talk to elementary school yeah it seems
like
picked on he was like yo stop my friends
kindness
isn't cool when you're in fifth sixth
grade but i promise you
it is the core foundation of having a
happy life
so stop being a dick
oh mic drop moment wow stop being a dick
you nine year old
he's just so cool kind of [ __ ] also i
do kind of like listen listen what the
messages to these young kids
listen there are people in this room
when they get on in the future and
they're running a 100 million dollar
business
running a 100 million dollar business is
the ideal success
money is how you're happy and worst get
respect
right kind of a woke uh counter argument
for me
maybe i'm just kidding you don't have to
defend
matter i think i'm i listen he's might
be a good guy i just honestly i'm i'm
digging here i'm
i'm pulling threads here but like this
was just why i i just love this video so
much you love the most in the world
my family once a day genuinely sit there
for five minutes and maybe pretend
i'm sorry that's hilarious no matter if
you love him or not that's just awesome
like i've seen videos of him for years
and i always thought he was like such a
joke i was like i thought he was super
cringe and
anytime my cousin was watching him i was
like how could you watch this guy but
i don't know i don't know how i actually
ended up just paying more attention to
him
i love your garyvee fan right tell me
about your uh
i'm not i heard him about him the first
time when we researched for the dock
or in this episode but oh i don't know i
think
when you say he's not real or he said he
was fake
i think it's kind of upset because he's
not lying he's telling the truth
who's more real me or gary vee exactly
yeah
but you didn't answer the question who
was maria
i thought it was just a question for uh
no i want an answer
not a rhetorical question yeah
technically him yeah you give it to him
turn his mic off there's no such thing
as the coincidence
all right you better sit at home tonight
imagine someone you love getting shot in
the face
of yeah yeah every night and report back
to us next week if it made you happy
actually that would be a good experiment
will you do that love
um sit down okay let's do an experiment
for real
would you be open to every day until
next friday
genuinely for five minutes imagine
someone you love being shot in the face
and then on friday let's see if you're
happier
okay yeah sure will you try it for real
yeah
okay genuinely now all right i mean
let's see
maybe he's wrong to something so
that's maybe not maybe you'll just be
cause i do agree that sounds pretty bad
so let's let's do it let's try it and if
you get like too depressed or like
gutted or something you don't have to
continue you can tell me if you want to
stop
i'll go i'll do it all yeah okay great i
look forward to seeing about hearing
about that on friday
it'll be interesting it's just a
shocking headline
he said it he said genuinely he
literally emphasized how serious he is
okay let me in my case for example my
grandmother basically raised me for
example and
she she has dementia now she does
dementia and you know it's very hard she
doesn't recognize me it's
something that's hard to think about i
try to stay busy and not think about
but in those moments like you know lena
comforts me and like losing my wife
is like i can't even imagine that it's
like a sadness that i can't even like
fathom
and like i don't know at least me
personally if i'm to think about that
it helps me be thankful for what i have
right now
genuinely sit are you gonna sit at home
from that five minutes every night
imagine lena getting shot in the face
also
my i might
i understand being appreciative for the
people around you
i want you to sit at home genuinely and
imagine her getting shot in the face
it just sounds to me like a bad
advice it's bad advice it's horrible
advice
it's like nothing makes me happier
literally
you're dealing with some [ __ ] but this
is not the solution
at least from the from what i'm hearing
i wouldn't want to do that to myself
you know but let's see love is going to
put himself through the meat grinder for
us
for different people's different things
it's so i think that's what it is
i think it's just different people
different things yeah it's so dark
yeah well it's so dark regardless of
whatever it is it's hilarious
all right well that's about it today huh
that's all we got i want to make some
shirts to sell for the lawsuit like
free ethan would you guys buy that or
lock him up
with with you know who which i won't say
because we're being nice right there's
no such thing as a coincidence
[Laughter]
the fact that you're watching this right
now means that you need to buy a
lock him up shirt
i'm not doing it thank you zach
we're about at the bottom of the show
here
i see people resounding saying no they
would not buy that shirt
thank you guys thank you for your
support from the same people that give
me ones on wikifeet when i'm 10 seconds
late got your hat thank you guys
thank you for all your support it's not
like i don't do anything for you
all right well that's about it the
episode today guys uh boy
been a good one eh pretty good oh i got
an interesting
email here oh you want to read it out
loud
um it's nothing interesting it's for my
lawyer he says just call him
okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna hang up i'm
gonna end the show and do that
all right so we'll be back with
frenemies on
you know the regular time monday tuesday
and uh
hey we'll see you guys next week it's
friday baby
yeah i finished my whole white club oh
you did yeah the whole day
yeah [ __ ] yeah baby i deserve it
what a fun app man my [ __ ] friday
[ __ ] the weekend baby
that was a fun episode yeah it was a
great up all right guys well be good
take care
and uh we'll see you next week all right
with more and e.t share relax with the
ring just see
how low jimmy lee they said we wouldn't
come back but you we always do embrace
from the ashes like the phoenix on the
flex back to two
you're watching h2333 you're watching
h2333
you're watching h233 you're watching
h233
ammo
[Music]
you